welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today my
guest is Dr Sarah Gottfried Dr Sarah
Gottfried is an obstetrician
gynecologist who did her undergraduate
training in bioengineering at the
University of Washington in Seattle she
then completed her medical training at
Harvard Medical School and she currently
is a clinical professor of Integrative
Medicine and nutritional Sciences at
Thomas Jefferson University she has also
been a clinician treating men and women
in various aspects of Hormone Health and
Longevity for more than 20 years
she is an expert in not just traditional
medicine as it relates to hormones and
fertility but also nutritional practices
supplementation and behavioral practices
and combining all of that expertise in
order to help women navigate every
aspect and dimension of their hormones
longevity and vitality ranging from
puberty to Young adulthood adulthood
perimenopause and menopause and nowadays
she's also treating men across the
lifespan in terms of longevity vitality
and Hormone Health during today's
discussion Dr Gottfried shares an
enormous amount of information and tools
that women can apply toward their
Hormone Health fertility vitality and
longevity we discussed the gut
microbiome which many people have heard
about but Dr Godfrey points out the
specific needs that women have in terms
of managing their gut microbiome and the
ways that that influences things like
estrogen levels and Metabolism
testosterone thyroid and growth hormone
and much more we also discussed
nutrition and exercise we touch on how
the omega-3 fatty acids play a
particularly important role in managing
female hormone Health Dr Gottfried
points out why women have particular
needs when it comes to essential fatty
acids and how best to obtain those
essential fatty acids for Hormone Health
we also discuss exercise and she offers
some surprising information about the
types and ratios of resistance training
to cardiovascular training that women
ought to use in order to maximize their
Hormone Health
we also talk a lot about the digestive
system this was a surprising aspect of
the conversation I did not anticipate Dr
Gottfried shared with us for instance
that women suffer from digestive issues
at more than 10 times the frequency that
do men and fortunately that there are
tools specific to women that they can
use in order to overcome those digestive
issues and that in overcoming those
digestive issues they can overcome many
of the related hormone issues that so
many women face Dr Gottfried also shares
with you tremendous knowledge about the
specific types of tests not just blood
tests but also urine and microbiome
tests that women can use in order to
really get a clear understanding of
their hormone status not just of present
but also where the trajectory of their
hormones is taking them so we have an
avid discussion about puberty about
young adulthood adulthood perimenopause
and how best to manage and navigate
perimenopause and menopause including a
discussion about hormone replacement
therapy in addition to her academic and
clinical expertise Dr Gottfried has
authored many import important books on
nutrition hormones and supplementation
as it relates to women and to people
generally the two books that I'd like to
highlight and that we've provided links
to in the show note captions are women
food and hormones and the hormone cure I
read the hormone cure and found it to be
tremendously interesting and informative
not just in terms of teaching me about
female hormone health and various
treatments for female hormone Health but
also as a man trying to understand how
the endocrine system interacts with
mindset nutrition and supplementation
more generally so I highly recommend the
hormone cure for anybody interested in
hormones and Hormone Health and women
food and hormones in particular for
women although again both books are
going to be strongly informative for
women wishing to optimize their Hormone
Health vitality and Longevity before we
begin I'd like to emphasize that this
podcast is separate from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford it is however
part of my desire and effort to bring
zero cost to Consumer information about
science and science related tools to the
general public in keeping with that
theme I'd like to thank the sponsors of
today's podcast cast our first sponsor
is Roka Roka makes eyeglasses and
sunglasses that are the absolute highest
quality I spent a lifetime working on
the biology of the visual system and I
can tell you that your visual system has
to contend with an enormous number of
challenges in order for you to be able
to see clearly so for instance when you
go from a very brightly lit area to a
dimlet area your visual system has to
make all sorts of adjustments that allow
you to still see your environment Roca
eyeglasses and sunglasses were built
with the biology of the visual system in
mind so no matter what environment
you're in you'll be able to see with
perfect clarity and they have terrific
Aesthetics an enormous number of choices
in terms of Aesthetics so unlike a lot
of so-called performance eyeglasses out
there that only give you the option to
wear the ones that make you look like a
cyborg they have those options but they
also have a lot of options with
Aesthetics that you would be perfectly
comfortable wearing to work or to dinner
or anywhere else if you'd like to try
Roca glasses you can go to roka.com
that's roka.com and enter the code
huberman to save 20 off your first order
again that's roka.com and enter the code
huberman at checkout today's episode is
also brought To Us by thesis thesis
makes custom nootropics and as many of
you know I'm not a fan of the word
nootropics because nootropics means
smart drugs and as a neuroscientist I
can tell you there is no neural circuit
in the brain for being smart thesis
understands this and has designed
different nootropics in order to bring
your brain into specific States for
specific types of work so for instance
for Creative work or to engage with more
Focus or to give you more energy for
cognitive or physical work so with
thesis they'll design custom nootropics
for you that will allow you more focus
better task switching more creativity
and so on and they'll be sure to include
only the ingredients that you want and
not the ingredients that you don't I've
been using thesis for more than a year
now and I can confidently say that their
neutropics have been a total game
changer for me I like the clarity
formula prior to Long bouts of cognitive
work or the Energy Formula prior to
physical workouts if you'd like to try
your own personalized nootropic starter
kit go online to takethesis.com huberman
you'll take a brief three-minute quiz
and thesis will send you four different
formulas to try on your first month
again that's takethesis.com huberman and
use the code Huber minute checkout for
10 off your first box today's episode is
also brought To Us by element element is
an electrolyte drink that has everything
you need and nothing you don't that
means the exact ratios of electrolytes
are an element and those are sodium
magnesium and potassium but it has no
sugar I've talked many times before on
this podcast about the key role of
hydration and electrolytes for nerve
cell function neuron function as well as
the function of all the cells and all
the tissues and organ systems of the
body
if we have sodium magnesium and
potassium present in the proper ratios
all of those cells function properly and
all our bodily systems can be optimized
if the electrolytes are not present and
if hydration is low we simply can't
think as well as we would otherwise our
mood is off hormone systems go off our
ability to get into physical action to
engage in endurance and strength and all
sorts of other things is diminished so
with element you can make sure that
you're staying on top of your hydration
and that you're getting the proper
ratios of electrolytes if you'd like to
try element you can go to drink element
that's lmnt.com huberman and you'll get
a free element sample pack with your
purchase they're all delicious so again
if you want to try element you can go to
element.com huberman the huberman Lab
podcast is now partnered with momentous
supplements to find the supplements we
discuss on the huberman Lab podcast you
can go to live momentous spelled ous
live momentous.com huberman and I should
just mention that the library of those
supplements is constantly expanding
again that's livmentis.com slash
huberman and now for my discussion with
Dr Sarah Gottfried Dr Gottfried Sarah
welcome thank you so happy to be here
yeah I'm delighted and very excited to
ask you about an enormous number of
topics here we are expert in so so many
things so uh the challenge for me is
going to be to constrain this walk as it
were but I'm hoping that we can touch on
a great number of things today the first
of which
is really about
hormones and female hormones in
particular and I have a question which
is
is it ever informative for a woman
regardless of age to know something
about
her mother's perhaps even her
grandmother's experience vis-a-vis
hormones not just pregnancy
challenges with or
um ease with pregnancy and child rearing
childbirth this sort of thing but you
know what sorts of conversations should
women be having with themselves and with
family members to get a window into what
their specific needs might be love this
question
so my work is really at the interface
between genetics and environment so your
question gets to
both
and I think it's essential that you
understand
what your
grandmother went through I'd even say
your great grandmother depending on
longevity in your family so I grew up
with my great-grandmother I get that
and especially your mother
so
I would probably start first with trauma
an intergenerational trauma because I
think that affects the endocrine system
so hugely especially cortisol signaling
but
the broader Pine system
psychoimmunuroendocrine system
and then there's you know if I think
about
the stages the life cycle that a woman
goes through
if you think about puberty I think I
don't know how
genetically determine the age of puberty
is certainly there's a lot of
environmental influences like toxins can
affect it
but
um pregnancy
the age at which you start to go through
perimenopause menopause many of those
have a genetic component
so with pregnancy I mean you can
certainly think
the shape of the pelvis your ability to
have a vaginal birth
some of that is genetically determined I
mean you do have you know the the sperm
donor affecting some of that but you
know in my family for instance we have
no cesarean sections so everyone goes
through this process of a relatively
easy vaginal birth I was a forceps baby
but you know for the most part
um you can find out about that and then
there's certain female conditions that
have a very strong component genetically
most of which run in my family so that
includes endometriosis
fibroids I just had a hysterectomy I
added 50 plus fibroids
and polycystic ovarian syndrome
and of those three uh how frequent are
those and maybe I can constrain the
question a little bit by saying
um today's discussion I imagine is going
to be heard by men and women of all
sorts of Ages so I uh maybe I'll direct
the question a little bit toward you
know at what age should these
discussions start
um you know we always imagine that women
in their 30s and 40s and 50s and onward
should be getting certain tests and
addressing things like uh ovarian
reserve and and other sorts of things
but you know maybe we could March
through and just say for a woman in her
teens who's already hit puberty what
sorts of biomarkers whether or not
they're blood-based or per or
um phenotyping you know the outward
appearance of uh
should those young women be paying
attention to likewise for women in their
20s 30s maybe we could take it more or
less by by decade at starting at puberty
assuming that woman hits puberty
sometime what between what is it now the
average in the U.S is somewhere between
12 and 16 years old do I have that right
no you do not oh great so that's to be
wrong so so it used to be 12 to 16. I
would say 50 years ago
it's been moving younger and we think
some of that is related to toxin
exposure as I mentioned but I was 10
when I went through puberty so uh well I
should say menarchy and I started
growing breasts much before that so
I think
now I'm going to step away from the
science for a moment I'm going to do
that pretty fluidly and I'll try to call
it out
I think there's also a huge influence
from stress
and like the development of the adrenal
glands
so going back to the science
the issue in teenage years is that the
hypothalamic pituitary adrenal axis
and I like to think of it broader so
stay with me hypothalamic pituitary
adrenal gonadol a recent women testes
men
thyroid
gut axis
so that to me is the control system so
I'm kind of
expressing my bioengineering side here
well I think it's great to include the
other organs and tissue systems of the
body because as we both know that the
narrow definition of just hypothalamic
pituitary adrenal it can't be just that
right no it can't no yeah it doesn't
tell the whole story
so if you look at
the
the main sex hormones
in a a young woman who's in her teenage
years the hypothalamic pituitary adrenal
gonadal part of that is not fully mature
so they're more likely to skip periods
especially under stress they have a lot
of influences it really doesn't get well
established until you're done with
adolescence and I'm told that
adolescence now is still like age 25 to
26. I heard that and I was like I've got
two daughters and I was like that's a
really long time and not just a
psychologically defined or bio
psychosocial mostly psychologically
defined I heard that from a psychologist
so
biomarkers you asked about in your
teenage years what I think is really
interesting is to look at cortisol
to look at the dance between estrogen
and progesterone in those years is less
helpful because I think there's a lot of
variability due to the immaturity of the
system if you've got someone who's got
really regular periods it's probably
better to do some benchmarking at that
age but generally I find that
benchmarking
is best performed in your 20s or 30s are
periods not that regular in terms of
duration of the menstrual cycle when the
menstrual cycle first sets in
it depends so I was like clockwork every
28 days until I had my hysterectomy in
August
same thing with my daughters I've got
two daughters one's 17 the other is 23.
for a lot of women they're not regular
and then there's the whole piece of oral
contraceptives and other forms of
contraception where you have no idea
what the normal cycle is and I hope
we'll have some time to talk a little
bit about oral contraceptives because I
think it is
this is now opinion again and not
science I think it is the number one
endocrinopathy
that is iatrogenic for women uh we will
definitely talk about it I get a lot of
questions about oral contraceptives
um in the social media space and also
questions about iuds quite a lot totally
in particular copper iuds
non-non-hormonal IUD so we will
definitely touch on that I'm an IUD
Crusader so I just want to you know give
you that warning you're you're a fan do
I have that right or you're anti I am a
huge fan which iuds in particular so I
like copper because it's non-hormonal
it's as effective as getting your tubes
dyed who would have thought right I mean
it's that toxic to the sperm Mobility is
that how it works that's my
understanding of it is that that it that
it basically it's like a
more or less an electric fence to the
the sperm cap and just that's it
electric fence is a bit of a harsh
analogy but I'll work with that
but it's
it's for 10 years so that you really
have
complete autonomy and sovereignty over
your sexual life
that's profound and to not get all those
Downstream risks they're associated with
a birth control pill the other thing
that's important to know about it I know
this is a sidebar
women who use the copper IUD
have the highest satisfaction rate of
anyone on contraceptives the highest
satisfaction rate and yet it is the
least used of all forms of contraception
now my favorite is vasectomy
but short of vasectomy I think the IED
is a really great choice there are some
risks associated with it I'm not saying
it's risk-free but I love IUD and I love
it for younger women too because it used
to be that when I went through my
training which was 30 years ago we were
told you know don't put it in someone
who hasn't had a baby
and that is patriarchal messaging
but getting back to your original
question which is about biomarkers per
decade
in your 20s
that's when you want to do some base
casing with estrogen progesterone and
testosterone
so I think it's really helpful to know
about this this Tango you're from
Argentina or your father I have
Argentine lineage yes my grandparents
did Tango into their late 80s I I am I'm
in my late 40s and I I still haven't
started so I suppose there's time it
might be time for you to okay and it
might be a factor in their longevity did
they have good health span and my
grandfather Smoked Cigarettes daily
remained mentally sharp until he died in
his late 90s but um almost burned down
their apartment several times falling
asleep with a cigarette in his mouth so
I don't recommend anyone Smoke by the
way uh but it was uh coffee mate uh red
meat and cigarettes and they lived into
their 90s so that side of my family has
the genetic Advantage the other side
less so
um but in any event uh Tango
um is a 2023 goal it has been every year
um the uh I'm gonna hold you accountable
today okay we'll do and there no there
will be no YouTube video of me do at
least not initially Tim Ferriss actually
a phenomenal podcaster as we know is uh
he's a badass he's a badass Tango Tango
dancer I know this through various
sources yes yeah I've seen yeah so this
Tango between us and progesterone is
incredibly important you want to have
the right lead do you want to have the
right follow between the two hormones
again I'm stepping away from my science
hat but what happens a lot of the time
is that estrogen dominates in that Tango
and when that happens it sets you up for
greater risk of fibroids endometriosis
breast pain
probably in association with the
microbiome and the estrobolume can you
familiarize me with the estrobloom yeah
I'm delighted to know that I don't
recognize the term yeah so the
estrobolume is the set of microbes
in and their DNA their DNA mostly
in the gut microbiome that set of
microbes in their DNA so it's in the
if you look at the totality
the subset
of particular bacteria modulate estrogen
levels
so a lot of this work was spearheaded by
Martin Glaser
and
what we know is that there are some
women who have an estrobolume that makes
them have a greater risk of certain
estrogen mediated
conditions like breast cancer
endometrial cancer
and a men prostate cancer
so the estrobulum is incredibly
important there's not a lot of attention
paid to it but I always think in terms
of my patients you know could this be
someone who's got a faulty a strobe and
we need to adjust it with you know some
of the microbiome
modulating
uh nutrients nutraceuticals that we have
so that they're less likely to have that
that Tango that's not working with
estrogen progesterone so getting back to
the biomarkers
if if you gave me an unlimited budget
which I kind of have with some of my
um clients that I work with now
what I would want to know is
estrogen progesterone testosterone and I
want the timing right for that
I'd want to know about DHEA and sort of
the whole Anderson pathway I'd want to
know about the metabolites of estrogen
because some of them are protective and
very helpful others are a bit like
Homer Simpson I mean they're just like
causing all kinds of problems in your
body increasing the risk of Quinones
like DNA damage and potentially an
increased risk of breast cancer although
that data I think is mixed
I'd also like to know about their stool
so I want to know about the microbiome
so the best that we have right now is to
look uh when we do stool testing I do a
lot of stool testing we can look at
things like beta glucoronidase
are you familiar with BG I'm familiar
with it as a term and so for those
listening it very often not always when
you hear an ace ASE you're dealing with
an enzyme so we can take a stab there
and and it sounds like it's somehow
involved in
um glucose metabolism of some sort or is
it clickeronautation so it's involved in
when you produce estrogen in the body
this is like the simplified version but
when you produce estrogen you are meant
to use it like send it to The receptors
where it's meant to go and then lose it
like you don't want to keep
recirculating the estrogen like Bad
Karma and that's what happens with
people who have high blade beta
gluconidase so it's this enzyme that's
produced by three bacteria in particular
in the gut and I see a lot of men and
women who have elevated beta
glucuronidase and then they have some
estrogen dominance related to that is
that the total reason we don't really
know but it's one of the drivers it's
one of the levers and it can be detected
from a microbiome AKA stool sample
that's right and in terms of blood
testing or various tests for these other
biomarkers getting estrogen testosterone
and other ratios I realize there are
people have different means financial
means but in general people wanting to
do a blood test it sounds like they're
going to need to do it what women will
need to do it at different stages of
their menstrual cycle if they had to
pick one
you know either in the follicular phase
and or in the luteal stage of their
ovarian menstrual cycle excuse me
ovulatory menstrual cycle
when would you suggest they do that if
they had to pick one so if you forced me
to pick one I would say
probably day 21 to 22 for someone in her
20s so we're focused right now in that
decade
so for most women they've got a
menstrual cycle Dave that averages out
at 28 days so this is about a week
before they start their period
for women or more irregular it's harder
to do that as women get older and we'll
talk about this in a moment
usually the cycle gets a little shorter
so as they start to decline in their
progesterone production their period
gets a little closer together like mine
before August was about every 26 days
so
at that point you want to test sooner
like day 1920 and I'm not talking about
blood tests so a blood test is the
cheapest thing it's usually what's
covered by insurance but my preference
would be to do dried urine
I like to use saliva for cortisol I like
to use dried urine so that I get
metabolomics in addition to the levels
of these hormones and if I'm forced to
I'll use blood testing and that's
certainly the gold standard
for all of these hormones that we're
talking about
but
um it's not as comprehensive and as you
know it's a quick little snapshot while
the needle's in your vein for you know
30 seconds yeah the salivary cortisol
makes sense to me because my
understanding is that you get free
cortisol which is the active cortisol
you said with urine you're also getting
the metabolites that's right and then
um for blood testing you're getting it
it's sort of a crude window into the
averages ecstatic total level
so uh let me go back and say one other
thing about biomarkers a big part of the
testing that I do in phenotyping my
patients I practice Precision medicine
so I I like to
almost start with nutritional testing
I don't think I've ever had a teenager
I've got some NBA players that are 19 20
21 so maybe those count
but uh those are men obviously but for
nutritional testing
that would be a potentially a helpful
thing to do in your 20s becomes less
important as you get older and you
develop more micronutrient deficiencies
but micronutrients play a huge role in
terms of hormone production magnesium
you know the Magnesium is hugely
involved in the way that you get rid of
estrogen as an example
so micronutrient testing what I usually
do is a combination of blood and urine
and so I'm looking at all of the
micronutrients that we can measure that
have some clinical scientific basis
behind them
if I could do that for a teenager I
think it might be helpful because
I recently gave a lecture on breast
cancer risk reduction
another quick sidebar
and I was sad to find that
intake of vegetables polyphenols is such
an important predictor a future risk of
breast cancer like when you're a 50 60
plus and the most important time is when
you're a teenager
now I have one daughter that eats
vegetables she loves them and I have
another daughter who eats food that's
beige and it's very hard to get her to
eat the volume of vegetables you know
five colors a day which is what I do
and
if you have evidence that you could show
a 17 year old that they've got
micronutrient gaps
I think that would be a motivator for
them to eat differently at a time when
it's so critical
even though it's you know 25 years in
the future that it's going to
potentially change this Arc that they're
on
what do you do for a young woman who
doesn't like vegetables is or is not
somehow able or willing to to get those
five colors a day of vegetable to help
support the microbiome
you know our supplements a useful tool
in that case
um what other sorts of tools Behavioral
or otherwise are useful such a good
question so here I'm going to invoke Rob
Knight at UCSD
so I think his his uh his gut project
has really been helpful in terms of
understanding what kind of modulators
are going to be important
so what I try to get that person to do
and I don't see many teens anymore other
than NBA players
what I try to get them to do is to have
a smoothie
very hard to get them to have a smoothie
every day but if I could get them to
have a smoothie three times a week and
to throw some of these vegetables in
that makes a huge difference I mean we
know that makes a difference in terms of
microbiome change she should be blending
up broccoli or kale cauliflower so
cauliflower is great even they're
putting things into the Smoothie yeah I
don't know if you can get a teenager to
do that but they often will use like I
have them do steamed broccoli that's in
the freezer because it's got very little
taste
so that they could do that in a
chocolate smoothie they could add some
greens I like greens powders are super
convenient so that with you know kind of
a taste that they like whether that's
chocolate which is what most my clients
want or you know vanilla with berries
and that sort of thing so that can go a
long way if you don't like vegetables
and short of that I would say some
supplements but I would say that's a
distant second to making a smoothie I've
got one patient that I have to mention
because
um
he took us to the extreme so he is a
retired physicist professor at UCSD he
found out that his microbiome was a hot
mess
and developed autoimmune disease and so
he became hell-bent like only a
physicist could on changing his
microbiome and he dramatically shifted
it by having a smoothie every day with
57 vegetables and fruits in it 57
independent 57 independent so
I mean this just warms my heart the way
that he did this but he would go to the
farmer's market he would just get a
bunch of this a bunch of that
and he would go home make the smoothie
and then stick it in the freezer so he'd
have a serving every day and he became a
completely different person based on
this microbiome change his
uh autoimmune disease is in remission
he um
he dropped a huge amount of weight he
went from being you know kind of this
phenotype that I know you know well of a
professor High performing traveling
around the world on so many boards so
much Innovation so many great ideas
super computer guy to being someone who
gets up in the morning gets in his hot
tub exercises for like one to two hours
a day
and then does a little work like he
completely shifted the way that he lives
and his microbiome shift you know who
knows what what's the chicken and what
the what's the egg there but he had a
huge change in his physiology glucose
went from being quite high he had
and he tracks all of this of course it's
like
Jupiter after all right and retired I
suppose might have had and he's retired
but he is he's got the longest time
series of anyone I know
and he's tracked his glucose and Insulin
going back 20 years
so he can show you okay here's where I
started having my smoothie
and here's how my glucose and Insulin
changed as a result of that I'd like to
take a quick break and acknowledge one
of our sponsors athletic greens athletic
greens now called ag1 is a vitamin
mineral probiotic drink that covers all
of your foundational nutritional needs
I've been taking athletic greens since
2012 so I'm delighted that they're
sponsoring the podcast the reason I
started taking athletic greens and the
reason I still take athletic greens once
are usually twice a day is that it gets
to be the probiotics that I need for gut
health our gut is very important it's
populated by gut microbiota that
communicate with the brain the immune
system and basically all the biological
systems of our body to strongly impact
our immediate and long-term health
and those probiotics and athletic greens
are optimal and vital for microbiotic
health in addition athletic greens
contains a number of adaptogens vitamins
and minerals that make sure that all of
my foundational nutritional needs are
met and it tastes great if you'd like to
try athletic greens you can go to
athleticgreens.com huberman and they'll
give you five free travel packs that
make it really easy to mix up athletic
greens while you're on the road in the
car on the plane Etc and they'll give
you a year's supply of vitamin d3k2
again that's athleticgreens.com huberman
to get the five free travel packs and
the year supply of vitamin D3 K2 is
there a case for I'll say young women
but young women and men using
over-the-counter probiotics as a way to
enhance the microbiome this is something
I hear about a lot I've heard that
excessive doses of capsule probiotics
can give a brain fog like condition
I personally don't use capsule
probiotics unless I feel like my system
is under a significant amount of stress
in which case I might add that in for
brief periods of time or if I've just
taken antibiotics for a period of time
do you ever recommend that the college
student or the high school student that
she or he take capsule probiotics
assuming that they're getting let's say
three to five servings of vegetables per
day either in smoothie form or some
other form what are your thoughts on on
supplementing probiotics
it sounds like such a simple question it
is such a complex answer and I don't
think we really have the answer so I'll
tell you the way that I approach it
I look for randomized trials to support
my use of probiotics and frankly I'm
underwhelmed
so I've seen some data
if I invoke my
um NBA players for a moment
almost every player I've tested has
increased intestinal permeability they
just have such a high training load
probably mediated by cortisol very high
glucosis when they drain that they have
increased intestinal permeability so
those tight junctions in their intestine
become loose they develop a lot of
inflammation as a result of that and
when you're a professional MBA player
and you're making 20 million a year
like you don't want a lot of
inflammation you want a little bit to
like help your muscles recover but you
don't want it to be
um adding to problems when you develop
an injury so this is leaky gut leaky gut
yeah I don't love that term but yeah
we'll use it here so there's a there's a
particular
probiotic that is helpful in athletes
with leaky gut so that's the kind of
specificity and randomized trial that
I'm looking for
the rest of it
I think there's support if you find help
from it as you described if you take a
course of antibiotics I mean first of
all I would question whether you need
them but I try and avoid them there have
been instances where they've been
prescribed and I took them mostly in the
past I was in college they seem like
they kind of gave them out you had a
sinus infection to give you Pro you know
antibiotics using like yeah the worst
treatment ever yeah so if you're coming
off of antibiotics I think that's a good
time to do what we call replacement dose
probiotics I think what's far more
interesting is
prebiotics I think the data is much
better for prebiotics and
um a selective use of polyphenols
how would a person in their teens and
20s or any age for that matter know
what whether or not they have
nutritional deficiencies what is the
best way to analyze if one is getting
enough magnesium and for that matter
what is going to be the best way to test
the microbiome you said stool sample and
I'll come right back with the same
question I asked about a blood test
what time of day when during the month
um to establish a baseline so this would
be prior to embarking on a you know 97
vegetables or how many years per day 57.
well I love the idea that you're telling
us if I'm gathering correctly is that
yes there's a case for probiotics but
for the typical person regardless of age
eating more vegetables or drinking more
vegetables as the case may be is going
to be beneficial for the gut microbiome
perhaps without the need to go test
whether or not one is making a certain
number of estrogen related metabolites
or not just that that's a great starting
Place eat or consume more vegetables
um but if one wants to analyze their gut
microbiome are there good tests
available to the general public this has
been I'm not going to name companies but
I've been tracking this over the years
and it's never been clear to me that we
know what constituents of the gut
microbiome are are best we know that
dysbiosis is bad yeah and we know that
diversity of the microbiome is good we
hear this yeah but no one's ever told me
that you want a particular ratio of one
microbiota to another right in a way
that has made any sense to me at least
totally I'm not a microbiologist but
whereas with you know with testosterone
in men we hear okay you want your free
testosterone to be about two percent of
your total perhaps with women you women
are gonna have more testosterone than
estrogen on average but still less than
men when you look at testosterone etc
etc but you can kind of get some some
crude measures but for the microbiome it
just seems like long lists of microbiota
for which I just get dizzy I just if you
just wrote out a bunch of I's and L's
and s's you'd you can go halfway a bit
bit the same information I'm not trying
to poke at that field it's a beautiful
field but they haven't told me what to
what I what my microbiota ought to look
like like what's a healthy microbiome
chart well that's because we don't know
I mean the best we have is Rob Knight's
work but even that is limited in terms
of you know can I tell you that a a
woman in her 20s should have this
particular pattern with her microbiome
no I can't so
um let me go to your first question
because I think you just asked about six
your first question is about nutritional
testing
what I like to do with nutritional
testing is run a panel that's looking at
antioxidants so like vitamin A vitamin C
alpha lipoic acid
um plant-based antioxidants because you
can measure that in the blood
I like to look at some of the key
vitamins especially the B vitamin range
because as you probably know if you've
got a particular genetic
um polymorphism so you might be less
likely to be absorbing the right level
of vitamin B9 folate vitamin B12 Etc
I'm also looking going back to the
antioxidants at glutathione because I
think that's such an important lever
when it comes to detoxification which we
haven't talked about yet
and then I'm looking at some of the
Minerals Magnesium is really the most
important and we know that somewhere
around 788 of Americans are deficient in
magnesium that's like the the lowest
hanging fruit I would be curious for
instance like with magnesium if that
number of people are deficient does that
mean that that number of people should
be targeting their nutrition towards
foods that contain magnesium and or
supplementing with magnesium and if so
what forms of magnesium we've talked
about mag three and eight for Sleep
there's a Mexican there's so many forms
it can be a little bit overwhelming to
people so any any detail in sourcing
would appreciate it great so first in
terms of testing what I prefer to do
is to mention one more than one lab and
more than one brand
um and I can just I'm speaking mostly
from experience so uh for testing I do a
lot of Genova neutrals
during the pandemic they developed an
at-home test normally with a neutral
valve you have to get your blood drawn
and you have to do a urine sample
so a lot of people can't do that the
great thing about this test is your
insurance usually pays for most of it
and so the copay is about 150 dollars
so during the pandemic they developed
another test called metabolomics which
does much of the same testing but it's a
finger prick
so most of my patients prefer that in
fact they haven't gone back to the
nutribal
second lab is spectracell
I use Spectra cell occasionally I find
it not quite as easy in terms of fitting
into my practice but I've got friends
and mentors like Mark Houston who does a
lot of
kind of Precision
cardiometabolic Health he thinks
spectrosol is the best test out there so
you asked about magnesium
you have to measure red blood cell
magnesium like whole blood
and with deficiency it's interesting
with
supplementation
for my patients who tend toward
constipation
and that's frankly about 80 percent of
the women that I take care of really yes
wow I'd be curious as to why that that
is
um is it I I can guess diet stress
um patriarchy
rage
to psychosis so Pine the um the pine
system right
psychology Immunology neural and
endocrine factors combined is that yes
and then I would say there's another
Factor
which is
being female is a health hazard
so we have twice the rate of depression
insomnia
we've got three to four x increased risk
of multiple sclerosis
we've got five to eight times the risk
of thyroid dysfunction
so if you just look at that and you look
at subtle pre-clinical thyroid
dysfunction
a huge number of the women that I take
care of well let me back off
a large number of the women that I take
care of have thyroid dysfunction that's
contributing to constipation and if we
go back to that control system the
hypothalamic pituitary adrenal thyroid
Canal gut axis
and they have a lot of perceived stress
together with this borderline thyroid
function that no mainstream medicine
doctor has told her is a problem and
then she's got a problem with the Tango
between estrogen and progesterone
she's going to tend toward constipation
women have a lot more constipation than
men
the gut is about 10 feet longer in women
compared to men
we should talk about some sex and gender
differences and Define those sure and
they are much more likely to have a
torturous colon
and the way you know that is you get a
colonoscopy and they tell you
yeah it's really hard to like get in
there and do what we need to do as a
brief tangent but I think this is the
time to ask
um at what age now do Physicians insist
their female patients get colonoscopies
for men I think the age used to be 50
now it's getting ratcheted back to 45 or
40. again these are recommendations not
requirements but they're pretty strong
recommendations from depending on where
you live Etc
um for women how early do you think they
should get a colonoscopy to to explore
for possible polyps and or colon cancer
yeah it's a really good question I don't
know the answer so what I've always
operated with is 50. the way that I
answer that is to go to the U.S
preventive task force rating to
determine based on their synthesis of
the data what age is the most
appropriate has it changed as you just
described for men from 50 to younger I
don't know so we should fact check that
all these um additional health hazards
for women
um you mentioned some of the
you broadly mentioned psychological
impact right and of course these things
are all related psychology immunology
and one of the I think wonderful things
about
neuroscience and Science in general and
medicine is that there's now an
understanding that all the organs are
connected to one another it's a network
it's a network and that the microbiome
sits at had um at a key node within that
Network
um and I think most people accept that
now yes yeah that seems to be a theme
that at least in the last 10 years is
really wonderful because
um certainly for Neuroscience it was
thought that you know unless it's in the
cranial vault
it's not neural which is ridiculous
because there's lots of nervous system
outside the skull but in any case can I
interrupt for a second yes please so I
think you're right that there's an
understanding about the network effect
but I think that
as much as I love mainstream medicine
and I trained in it and I'm so grateful
for my education I still think it is a
silo based way of taking care of
patients so even if there's an
understanding of the network effect more
at the science level or as you described
in Neuroscience there's still you know
if you are a woman who has constipation
fatigue
um
maybe an autoimmune condition
feel stressed out all the time feel like
your hormones are out of whack you get
sent to the gastroenterologist for the
constipation you get sent to the
rheumatologist for your autoimmune
issues you maybe get sent to an
endocrinologist if you've got thyroid
problems and there's very little
collaboration between these groups so
even though there's an understanding of
the network effect
in real life it's not happening
let's um let's go deeper down that path
because I you point out something really
important and you've mentioned
constipation a few times can we view
constipation as a serious enough symptom
that it warrants an immediate
intervention that is does it flag or
signal
problems that are severe enough that
that should be the issue that's dealt
with uh for anybody that's experiencing
it yeah and I mean sort of an odd topic
for many people because they think oh
you know bowel movements and sort of you
know there's that kind of um
pre-adolescent humor around this but I
think it's it's so important when you're
what I'm hearing you say is that
constipation is far more common in women
and it signals a general many problems
occurring does that mean that women
should address constipation and if so
what's the best way to address
constipation yeah I love this question
because
you're doing can we have a quick little
meta conversation so you're doing
something that I knew you would do which
is
you're teaching me something and you're
changing like there's a social genomics
thing happening where you're changing my
thought about this so I just wanted to
acknowledge that thank you thank you
well I think for me you know when I hear
that there's a kind of you know you're
talking about a phenotype constipation
is a phenotype it's one that people
generally don't wear a t-shirt
explaining it to people but that I'm
guessing anything to do with sexual
health
um bowel Health Urology people just
don't talk about right
um for all sorts of reasons and those
reasons are probably so obvious that
they're not even worth discussing but
because and also because we won't change
them except by talking about them yep so
if you say
um women are far more constipated and
that's signaling a larger set of
problems yes then my immediate thought
is well will relieving constipation
um pun uh intended retroactively
um will that assist in a great number of
issues and or will it get them down the
road of thinking about those other
issues more specifically like do I need
more magnesium or should I be putting
vegetables in my smoothie you know so
I'm curious about constipation as a
Target yeah for intervention that then
opens up a bunch of other discussions
because there are these certain nodes in
the in the mental health physical health
space that when someone you know like we
talk a lot of deliberate cold exposure
do I think it's magic no but I think
that if someone's getting themselves
into a cold shower once a day it opens
up a nun a number of questions about
themselves and reveals a number of
things to themselves like how do I
buffer stress yeah what sorts of levels
of control do I actually have and on and
on so perhaps not the best example but
some of us hate cold exposure right
which is we have we have like a gene
that makes us stress out like you
wouldn't believe which I would argue
makes it
um very likely that even 10 seconds of
cold exposure gets you the effect that
you want as opposed to someone who
adores cold exposure like a penguin
needs a lot more cold exposure for it to
have the the Adaptive response anyway
that's my way of gumbing through that uh
quite uh you're you're quite correct
um so so let's answer those questions
constipation issue yeah so this is how
you're changing the way I think about
this
so you're asking okay instead of looking
at constipation as a constellation of
symptoms what about if you just used it
on its own as sort of a
um
a key
indicator or signal
of dysfunction with my network or maybe
something broader
and I think that's right
so it makes me think of a few things it
makes me you're also changing this book
that I'm writing on autoimmunity and
Trauma so thank you for that so
women experience more trauma than men
this is well established if you look at
the ace studies that were done by the
CDC in Kaiser in 1998 we know that men
for the most part middle-aged men have
about
um
about 50 of them experience significant
trauma as defined by the ace
questionnaire women are at 60 and that's
pretty durable since 1998. so women have
more they have different forms of abuse
much more likely to have sexual abuse
they have a different HPA response than
men
their perceived stress tends to be
higher and I'm generalizing for a
population
side note you know in Precision medicine
we don't do that we do medicine for the
individual individual not the population
not medicine for the average
and so if you look at
the physiology of a female
I think that constipation and that need
to like control and restrain and hold
things in
you know tighten the anal sphincter
I think that's part of the physiology
so I'm veering away from the science but
I do think that it is a really important
signal to pay a lot of attention to now
you also asked about microbiome testing
should we do that or do yeah well I have
a couple more questions about
constipation I never thought I'd ask
this many questions about concentrating
but now I'm fascinated by the way also
this morning I taught medical students
at Stanford about the fact that we are
basically a series of tubes so you
talked about the the anal sphincter we
are a set of sphincters from one end to
the other I mean we are a set of tubes a
nervous system being one of those tubes
and well and I think in eastern medicine
they talk about the various locks
between those tubes and Chambers and
it's not without coincidence there's
some real wisdom there of course wait
did you just talk about energetic
Anatomy uh more or less I didn't say the
word chakras but uh but I might in
passage it's the bondas right are the
are the are the the sphincters yes yes
that's right uh thank you for for that
the um so what defines constipation I
mean in other words let's think about
the healthy rather than thinking about
the unhealthy let's how many bowel
movements should a woman or a man have
per day assuming this is where it gets
tricky because some people are doing
time restricted feeding some people are
eating more some people eat more fiber
more bulk larger meal at the end of the
day a larger meal the beginning of the
day we will never
um be able to sort out all those
variables but on average
um how many bowel movements and his
timing
during the day for bowel movements at
all informative what works for you
um well when I'm asleep
um generally I don't want a bowel
movement so I'm going to be like most
people right well sleep is primary for
you right exactly um I always assumed
that morning time yeah was a was a
healthy time for bowel movements um and
I think almost everybody babies included
recognize the feeling of being lighter
and more energetic when they've
evacuated totally colon totally um in
fact so much so that I'm obsessed with
jungian and Freudian psychology that the
first thing we learn when we come into
this world right is that we want
something we we feel some sort of
autonomic arousal stress whether or not
it's food or warmth or the need to have
a bowel movement one of the first things
that parents learn is how to recognize
that not by the odor coming from the
diaper but by the look on the baby's
face or their agitation agitation
signals the need for some sort of relief
right temperature relief food relief
um evacuating the bowel relief so my
understanding is that as autonomic
arousal increases in the early part of
the day ideally after a good night's
sleep that bowel movements become more
likely unless that arousal becomes so
great that then people feel so quote
unquote locked up right
um because of the balance of the
autonomics of features so early day I'm
guessing and again in the second half of
the day and here I'm totally guessing
um and certainly not having to wake in
the middle of the night
um yeah those are my best guesses
that's great so I would agree with that
when I was at Harvard Medical School in
UCSF for residency I was taught that
constipation is having a bowel movement
less frequently than whenever once every
three days
so I don't think I've ever laughed out
loud on this podcast as a consequence of
of uh textbook medical knowledge are you
kidding me is that ridiculous well that
sounds like and and here pun intended
that sounds like the uh the conclusion
of some very um constipated personally
and and and and in other ways
constipated individuals and again this
might seem like an odd conversation but
the the discussion around conservation
is is present in psychological
literature yes because of this
relationship to the autonomic system
well it's a metaphor in literature
it's crucial so you you spoke to a
number of different threads that I think
are important here so that's the
definition that I learned and I was I
heard that and I was like hell no that
doesn't work for me it doesn't work for
anyone I know
and I spent a lot of time especially in
medical school and in my internship
where you rotate on medicine
disimpacting
women like older women who come in who
haven't had a bowel movement in a month
whoa and that let me tell you that is
not nice for anybody yeah believe me I
became a scientist not a physician for a
number of reasons both positive and
negative that's one of them yeah so my
definition of constipation as a western
mostly white girl
is that if you're not having a bowel
movement every single morning and you
have a feeling of complete evacuation
anything less than that is constipation
so that's how I Define it if you're in
India and you're eating food that's got
a fair amount of microbes in it it's
less you know sanitary I'm using that
word
um as carefully as I can
generally they have a bowel movement
after every meal
but they've got a different microbiome
they're exposed to different microbes
here in the U.S I would say Wednesday
you also spoke to something very
important which is the balance between
the parasympathetic nervous system rest
and digest and poop versus the
sympathetic nervous system kind of the
on button you know
fight
flight freeze spawn
so I think for those of us who've got
issues with autonomic balance
it can lead to constipation and I like
that constipation could be pulled out
and kind of writ larger as an important
signal what sorts of tools do you
recommend people use to
um
relieve constipation
um in eating more fiber sounds like
reducing stress is going to be a huge
one yes what are your favorite stress
reduction tools
um I like to divide these into
real-time tools so a big proponent of
like physiological sign real time you
know these sorts of things but things
that can really lower the Baseline on
stress overall to facilitate
constipation and other other broad
indicators of Health
so I'm not a fan of lowering stress I'm
a fan of lowering perceived stress and I
think the distinction is really
important
I learned when I was in my 30s that
I was a massive stress case and I didn't
know it it was just sort of
I think I through residency through
working 120 hours a week I just was so
accustomed and sort of
um that was 120 not under 20 folks yeah
not unusual in in medicine well they
they've changed training so that you
work no more than 80 hours a week now
but that was before my time
so
I became
accustomed to a massive amount of
cortisol massive
and
I would say I've spent the past 20 years
really working on perceived stress to
find I think all of us in all a cart
menu
of what is most effective
so what works for me now at my age is
different than you know the the TM I did
as a college student Transcendental
Meditation it's different than the I
became a certified yoga teacher when I
was in my 30s that is very effective for
a lot of people
it wasn't enough for my Matrix
I do holotropic breath work
um I didn't read it but I saw it she
just had a paper and sell on your sign
and
um it kind of it made me think like
teach me how to teach teach me how to
sigh like can you say a little bit about
that like how do you do it yeah very
briefly that study was we we wanted to
find a minimal effective dose
intervention yeah I just wanted yeah so
five minutes a day we need to figure out
what people do every day yeah and we
were monitoring
subjective mood Etc but also Biometrics
remotely so it's kind of a nice
Biometrics HRV HRV uh nighttime sleep
cortisol uh I wish
um so this was done during the pandemic
more than 100 subjects the advantage was
that we got data 24 hours a day because
they're pinging us in their data uh
wearing HRV 24 yeah nice so that was
nice resting heart rate
um subjective mood we would get in touch
with them daily so when people were
swapped between groups like any good
study but five minutes a day of sort of
standard if you will forgive me
meditations are just sitting no
instructions about how to breathe just
focusing on
um closing their eyes and focusing on
focusing yep
um another group did box breathing yep
inhale hold exhale hold for equal
durations the duration of each of those
inhales and holds was set by their
carbon dioxide tolerance so somewhere
between three and eight seconds
depending on how well they regulate
carbon dioxide
another group did cyclic signs so this
would be double inhale through the nose
so big inhale through the nose
followed by it to lungs empty exhale
that second inhale after the first big
long inhale through the nose is really
important because it makes sure that all
the collapsed abiola the lungs totally
snap open and then the exhale you
offload a lot of carbon dioxide that's
very similar to holotropic breath work
not yes not not
um not unlike holotropic breath we're a
little bit pranayama-ish but the exhale
is rather passive as opposed to active
and then the fourth category was cyclic
hyperventilation which is a lot like
Tumo AKA Wim Hof ish breathing different
than Wim Hof breathing so this would be
so very active inhales and exhales
every 25 cycles of inhale exhale that'll
be one cycle long exhale hold lungs
empty 15 to 30 seconds then repeat for
about five minutes now the info everyone
did that for five minutes and what we
found was that the cyclic sign led to
the greatest improvements in mood Around
the Clock not just around the the
practice or during the practice as well
as lowered resting heart rate
improvements in sleep
Etc and you got it publish and sell yeah
we were so amazing we're very fortunate
I think um the the thankfully the
reviewers and editors understood that
these minimal intervention things uh
hopefully are going to be of use to
people so so useful to people I mean how
often do you read a paper like that that
could offer a behavior change
that is so easy to implement I mean I
love that question thank you so what
about did you tell them not to drink
because alcohol has such a huge effect
on HRV yeah so in this case we didn't
tell them to alter anything else about
their behavior just hoping it was
background kind of across the system yes
and some were Stanford students others
were from the general population any
Frat Boys that were drinking heavily
probably not well during the pandemic I
think alcohol intake went way way up
across the board
um I mean isn't if I had a magic wand I
would I would ask that people either not
drink or drink two drinks per week
maximum at least that's my understanding
of the literature
um are you familiar with the whoop data
with alcohol no but we have a
collaboration with through that paper
yeah um and it certainly disrupts
patterns of nighttime sleep in
particular from my understanding that
first phase of sleep that's related to
the massive growth hormone release that
you all really need and want in
different measure growth hormones we did
not no the second iteration of this
study will certainly include free
cortisol by saliva hormone panels well
I'm beginning to think that we should
also
um be asking people how often they're
going to the bathroom and what time of
day yes I mean this thing around
constipation is uh is super interesting
and I think that plus um blood markers
and then I'm I'm very excited to learn
that
um that urine contains additional
markers that could be informative so
yeah it was it was a fun study uh not
easy study to do with that number of of
subjects um takes a lot of training for
your research assistants yeah it was a
big group it was nine people in our
group and three clinicians and a lot of
a lot of phone calls and a lot of back
and forth but you know and thank you to
the subjects who served as the uh the
real life guinea pigs so yeah I think
that stress you know people's I think
people are starting to appreciate that
there are ways that they can relieve
their stress that that don't only fall
under the categories of vacation right
and meditation but I want to say that
meditation is obviously a wonderful tool
um it's just it's a it's a tool not
unlike any other tool that is great for
some people and less great for others
well certainly it's a great tool and
it's got such a scientific basis behind
it
but there's so many things on this a la
carte menu sex orgasm
um connection
feeling heard and seen and loved
um yeah let's talk about that you know
you mentioned earlier that all these
stress factors you you said patriarchy
right yeah but I think what if I may
um at risk of uh of just strengthening
that uh statement I I mean that that to
me is is signaling a bunch of other
factors around us you said like keeping
keeping things in
um
what do you think explains let's talk
about that because I think that that's
likely to have raised a certain flag in
people's minds like what exactly is she
talking about are you talking about less
opportunity are you talking about less
opportunity to
um to vocalize are you talking about
less opportunity to vocalize and be
heard I mean I realize that there are an
infinite number of variables but given
that it sounds like a really strong
input to the system uh what I mean by
that is that psychology is influencing
biology and you're saying that that
these uh
that these power power dynamics
structures and Dynamics are impacting
I'd love let's hear your thoughts on
that because uh I I hate to let a flag
like that go by without fleshing it out
and never waste a good flag well and
let's preface it by by just saying that
like people will have different opinions
on this and that's and I think that's
healthy and like with the discussion
about constipation let's talk about what
people aren't willing to talk about when
it comes to health love it so we might
need to talk about patriarchy on part
two but I'll give you some material that
I've been working with
I started I did not even understand the
existence of patriarchy until I was a
bioengineering undergraduate at MIT I
should mention which has always had a
bit of a of a male
um askewed male in terms of Faculty
numbers well my my that's true at most
universities true well my postdoc
advisor was the late Ben Barris who was
a female to male transition transgender
interest first transgender member in the
National Academy of Sciences were my
closest friends unfortunately he died of
of pancreatic cancer we were very very
close they're actually making a
documentary about Ben but Ben this is
interesting Ben went to MIT because he
wanted to be around a lot of men yeah
that's a lesser known fact but then he
was a very strong advocate for women he
went as Barbara when he was Barbara and
um by the way he's given me permission
to share all this prior to his death I
recorded a lot of conversations yeah
um I only ever knew him as Ben by the
way but when he was at MIT he was
identified female and he later talked
about the intense
um
suppression oppression literally is how
he described it especially given that he
was performing so well yes so you just
defined patriarchy
you did it yourself
a couple things
when I was in bioengineering
I took a women's studies class
and it was all about teaching
undergraduates about the existence of
patriarchy which I would Define maybe at
its simplest as power over
I'm not saying men are patriarchy I'm
saying something very different which is
power over
let me correct one thing that you said I
didn't go to MIT as an undergraduate
so I'm from I was in Alaska and I went
to the University of Washington for
bioengineering in Seattle in Seattle
okay I dropped out of a graduate program
in bioengineering to go to the Harvard
MIT
program for Health Sciences and
technology in Boston thanks for that
clarification University of Washington
also wonderful place I have many many
many many many many many wonderful close
colleagues there it's an incredible
place especially for vision science
it's especially good for engineering
bioengineering but
um yeah so my my MD is jointly between
MIT and Harvard and it's the oldest
maybe largest although Harvard says this
a lot program for biomedical engineers
and uh MD phds physician scientist
training program
great thanks for that clarification I'm
going to blame the internet for this one
I am I think we need to send our our
Wikipedia editors out there I think
LinkedIn is correct okay great well
Wikipedia editors note get out there and
make that make the correction now you
heard it
um so
stress that is what you're really
talking about is systemic stress in the
body as a concept as a consequence
excuse me of systemic stress of
environment that's right
you know there's particular forms of it
I would say this also relates to
White Privilege it relates to
racism
and when you look at
you know kind of the way that systems
including my beloved MIT
the way that they're set up is that
might make us makes right
and generally the people that are the
strongest
you know big men strong men they're the
ones who tend to be the most successful
so for people who are bipoc for people
who don't have white privilege for women
it's a different experience and so I'm
using patriarchy as kind of a
umbrella here but it connects to many
other things
I'd like to take a brief break and thank
our sponsor inside tracker inside
tracker is a personalized nutrition
platform that analyzes data from your
blood and DNA to help you better
understand your body and help you reach
your health goals I've long been a
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors that impact your immediate
and long-term Health can only be
analyzed from a quality blood test the
problem with a lot of blood and DNA
tests out there however is that you get
data back about metabolic factors lipids
and hormones and so forth but you don't
know what to do with those data
insidetracker solves that problem and
makes it very easy for you to understand
what sorts of nutritional behavioral
maybe even supplementation based
interventions you might want to take on
in order to adjust the numbers of those
metabolic factors hormones lipids and
other things that impact your immediate
and long-term Health to bring those
numbers into the ranges that are
appropriate and indeed optimal for you
if you'd like to try inside tracker you
can visit insidetracker.com huberman and
get 20 off any of inside hackers plans
that's inside tracker.com huberman to
get twenty percent off I want to use
this as an opportunity to a keep this in
mind as I return to a question that I
didn't close the hatch on earlier and
it's my fault which is I'm now clear on
the fact that a woman in her late teens
early 20s ought to know something about
her testosterone estrogen thyroid
cortisol levels
should start at least thinking about her
microbiome
should be thinking about
how how many bowel movements and the
timing of those bowel movements per day
really and
I'm assuming that what I just described
is also true for women in their 20s 30s
40s 50s on up to hundreds is that
correct
that's correct but I would say that
there are
differential opportunities
by decade
so I'm glad she circled it back to
teenagers and testosterone because I
think if you know
for instance in your teenage years that
you have high androgens and that you've
got this potential phenotype way into
the future that you may not even notice
I mean maybe you notice you've got a few
extra hairs on your chin or something
if you know that your testosterone is
elevated or some other androgen it might
change the Arc of how you take care of
yourself so I think that could be very
helpful in your teenage years in your
20s for people who are a stress case
like me so age 27 on the words at UCSF
if I had known that I was such a high
cortisol person
I think I would have done things
differently I would have changed my
behavior
and I don't know because I didn't base
case these but
your testosterone
can decline starting in your 20s kind of
depending on how much stress your Matrix
is under so for women that can start as
early as 28 usually your testosterone
declines by about one percent per year
what level of testosterone do you like
to see in a woman once she's sort of
post let's say after age 25 what kind of
range is healthy I know what the
reference range is only because I know
one could look it up I don't know it's
off the top of my head immediately but
what what's a kind of a nice reference
point there so the way I tend to
describe this on podcasts is the top
half of the normal range great
so that I think is a good benchmark
you know for PCOS
generally it's much higher than that you
know I've seen patients with PCOS where
their total testosterone is 100 to 200.
do they always have peripheral
manifestations of that a little bit of
hair the the skin plaques I've heard
about you know so darkened skin
irregular periods regular periods is
that
um you know I get a lot of questions
about PCOS yeah
um and you're the first person we've had
on this podcast that's really qualified
to talk about PCOS in a real way
um so here we're talking about too many
androgens cysts on the ovary irregular
ovarian
excuse me I keep saying that ovulatory
slash menstrual cycle
um
what are some other indicators and do
you recommend that women start taking
Androgen blockers or so or I mean how do
seems to be a lot of PCOS out there I'm
hearing about it a lot
so glad you asked about this so PCOS is
one of those really
poorly understood conditions that gets
it kind of flows flies below the radar
until a woman wants to get pregnant or
she's got some other issue that drives
her to a physician
the problem is that it is a syndrome
right so polycystic ovary syndrome
sometimes polycystic ovarian syndrome
and syndromes don't necessarily fit
together into a really clear diagnostic
criteria
so in this instance there are three
different criteria that we look for so
this is on the ovaries having
um clinical manifestations of
hyperandrogenism so that could be
hirsutism acne other things and then
usually irregular periods and the way
that that's defined at least by the uh
latest criteria is having a period every
35 days or less
so typical cycle length 28 is 35 days
you know you're skipping a period here
and there
so those are the those are the criteria
that we use to diagnose PCOS there are
about four different systems out there
in the literature for diagnosing PCOS
which is where it starts to get
confusing so there's some women who have
gnosis on their ovaries but they've got
hirsutism and they've got irregular
periods could you define haircitism here
statism is increased hair growth usually
in places that you don't want it so for
women it can be you know kind of male
pattern they might notice it on their
breasts on their chest
um
and then there's of course a familial
quality to that like I was just looking
at a paper last night looking at
Israelis and how much hair statism they
have and whether this is related to CH E
repeats on the Androgen receptor
do they get um not Israelis but um do
women who
um who might have PCOS experience um
androgenic alopecia so hair loss that's
sort of of the quote-unquote male
pattern baldness of course it's Androgen
pattern baldness as opposed to male
we're talking about testosterone DHT
related sometimes you know this is where
I'm going to invoke clinical experience
rather than what I've seen in the
literature women definitely can have
some androgenic alopecia
I tend to see it later in life
but this is an important point because
we think of PCOS as you know I was just
talking about it in teenage years like
wouldn't it be nice to know that you
have this phenotype and you're at risk
for all the things that people are at
risk for and we haven't talked about
glucose and Insulin yet we should
what we know is that
PCOS is not just a problem in terms of
irregular periods and then difficulty
getting pregnant so those are mostly
problems in your 20s 30s early 40s but
it is a massive risk factor for
cardiometabolic disease as you get older
so many people tend to pigeonhole PCOS
is a problem of reproductive age we have
to be thinking of it over the entire
female life cycle and I would say it's
even more important to consider it over
the age of 50 you know average age of
menopause is 51-52 because we know that
that elevated testosterone the high
androgens
are probably the greatest cardio
metabolic driver of disease for women
with PCOS wow now one other thing I want
to mention and I still have my notes
that we're going to talk about
microbiome testing because that's such a
fun subject
what I was taught to do
again saying this was so much love for
the people who have taught me how to do
medicine what I was taught to do is that
if you have a woman with PCOS you make
the diagnosis you measure her
testosterone you see if she has acne
blah blah
you ask that woman one question
do you want to get pregnant or not
so then you have these women with PCOS
who get started on a birth control pill
if they don't want to get pregnant if
they want to get pregnant then you help
them get pregnant by addressing some of
these PCOS issues like maybe you give
them Clomid or you do something to make
them ovulate more frequently
that is the way that most conventional
medicine approaches this and it does
women at gigantic disservice so one of
the things I'm speaking into is the
gender gap that exists so I my feeling
is that the research money that goes
into women's health is abysmal compared
to what goes into mental health really
and I think that's changing but there's
also a huge lack of awareness of sex and
gender differences when it comes to the
way that we construct
clinical trials and other experiments
well that's absolutely true I mean I sit
on I've sat on NIH review panels for
more than a decade now I'm a regular
standing member which is only to say
that I see the research as it's being
proposed yes and now
it's required no Grant will get funded
without
sex as a biological variable and here
I'm by the way folks this is sex
biological sex the noun not sex the verb
both are super interesting obviously but
um when we say sex is a biological
variable meaning even if it's a study on
mice how did that start though that
didn't start that long ago it must have
been I think we can think
I don't want to miss attribute here I
think we can thank Francis Collins for
insisting on this amen Francis
Bernadine Healy has done so much to help
us but you know she made the Women's
Health Initiative which I hope will get
to
which is a hot mess like so confusing
the data that came out of that yeah so
and these trials are long and so the
data are only now starting to emerge so
just to be clear I mean I have a a
question that I don't think is going to
take us off track but this is I'm going
to pose this question as a hypothesis
because I think it's likely to be a
little bit of a of a not a barbed wire
question but maybe like a prickly
question when people first hear it but
it's posed as a hypothesis you mentioned
some of the psychosocial stress issues
based on at the organizational level
institutional level societal level maybe
right down to the family and and just
life that are biasing Health outcomes
for the worse in female populations okay
you refer to as the patriarchy I'm just
trying to put it make sure that we're
both talking about the same thing and
that's non-exhaustive I realize that's
just a subset of the issues
I'm also hearing there's a lot more PCOS
which is hyper androgenization of the
ovary in there we're talking about you
mentioned you know excess testosterone
which females naturally have more
testosterone than they do estrogen
anyway but we're talking about elevated
levels
here's a hypothesis one hypothesis would
be that the increased androgens and the
pieceo PCOS are a consequence of the
psychosocial conditions that are
I don't say forcing but are biasing the
need for females to
um think behave react act in certain
ways
to survive let alone Thrive is that a I
don't say this for any kind of political
correctness hypothesis this is a in my
this would be a fun interesting and I
think important study to run right
depending on stress and the conditions
the specific
type of stress do females under produce
or over produce androgens or is it a
neutral effect does that make make sense
I love this question so let me just
paraphrase the last part of it to make
sure I got it
it sounds like what you're asking is
could PCOS or at least some phenotypes
of PCOS be a response to what I'm
calling patriarchy
and then you add a second part to it
which is do healthy women
like what is their production of
testosterone like is that right yes and
and with the acknowledgment I mean
you're the expert here
um you're the physician clinician an
expert in hormones and I'm not but with
the understanding that absolute levels
of hormones are interesting but perhaps
not as interesting as the ratios of
testosterone to estrogen so when we're
talking about excess testosterone we're
really not talking about oh women making
a lot of testosterone because frankly
they already make a lot like then most
people that weren't aware of that I
wasn't aware that women make more
testosterone right and so it's not
saying that testosterone in women is bad
or is always a reaction to the
environment yes but when it becomes
um super physiological or hyper elevated
is I could imagine all sorts of social
conditions that would create that so in
males and females but here we're talking
about PCOS and females in particular so
I'd love for you to speculate
um should we run the study we should
totally run the study because
I don't know the answer
I suspect that you're onto something
it may not explain all of the women with
PCOS because as I mentioned there's a
lot of different phenotypes but I think
it could explain
a significant portion
and you know you're almost you're saying
if we look at the gene environment
interface this environmental influence
of having being someone who's got power
over you if if PCOS was a response to
that
the way that we treat it would be
completely different
so on the one hand I want to be careful
not to dismiss the suffering and
experience of women with PCOS I've got a
lot of women with PCOS in my family and
it is
there's so much pain and suffering you
know especially if you want to have a
baby and you try for years and you just
can't ovulate
on the other hand
I read a paper recently and maybe we
could cite this
that compares the phenotype of a woman
with PCOS to a man who is hypoandrogenic
and I think that's a really interesting
way to look at this because
the thread we haven't talked about with
PCOS is the the role of insulin and
glucose
so for some of the phenotypes of PCOS
the problem is hyper insulin emia High
insulin in the blood is driving those
thika cells and ovaries to overproduce
testosterone these women are insulin
insensitive so
more insulin is being cranked out
and these cells in the ovary are
therefore making more Androgen you don't
like to say insulin resistant oh I I can
uh I don't have a problem saying okay
I'm just a little bit outside the lane
lines of my expertise so I was trying to
use it what is the correct nomenclature
so that we can make sure well what I
like about insulin insensitive the way
that she just said it is that I think
that offers people a way in and I love
to do that in terms of messaging insulin
resistance starts to lose people because
they don't really get what that means at
a receptor level I think I say insulin
insensitive because when people hear
insulin sensitive it almost sounds like
a bad thing but that's actually what you
want so I think I think that's how I
defaulted to insulin what's your insulin
I don't know what I'm due for a blood
test yes you are I'm due for a blood
test um I had blood work done for eight
months um sure that'd be great I uh I'm
always
um experimenting with different
supplements and different behavioral
regimens and I've kept charts since I
was 19. oh you're like my patient I I've
been sort of Obsessed by this and I
would say
everybody if you can afford it and at
the time actually I had to save up
Insurance wouldn't cover it
um get some basic blood work done so you
have a reference do it as soon as
possible because even you know the we've
been talking about these women over the
life cycle
I wish I knew what my insulin was when I
was a teenager I wish I wish I knew what
my fasting insulin was I really wish I
knew my postprandial insulin like in my
teenage years in my 20s in my 30s well I
knew it in my 30s starting at 35. are
you a fan of continuous glucose monitors
the hugest most gigantic fan of cgms
I've never seen any tool that I've ever
used in medicine change Behavior the way
that cgms do wow why do you think they
are so effective at changing Behavior
I've tried one and I really liked it I
learned that in the sauna my insulin or
my blood glucose goes up probably by a
bit of dehydration I learned what kind
of foods work for me which don't
um I thought it was fascinating I
learned how every Behavior you could
possibly imagine use your imagination
impacts blood glucose totally totally
fascinating to me including how a
two-way wake-ups during the middle of
the night versus one versus none
impacted blood glucose the next morning
fascinating for a data junkie like me it
was like I was in heaven
um why do you think they are so
effective in changing behavior is it
because of that that people can see that
real-time control like scan in and like
oh that's the that's the sandwich I
think it's I think it's many things I
think it's
generally the enchantment
of learning about your own chemistry and
biology I love it and I think for me
what I've seen you know I feel like
doctors are basically marketers
like the sacred marketing like our job
as a physician is to convince people
to do something that we think is good
for them based on the best science
but we can't just say here I wanted to
fill this prescription for a ctm you
have to Market it you have to say
I think this completely changes the way
that you approach your pre-diabetes I
think this could dramatically affect
your risk of Alzheimer's disease that
you're so worried about that your mother
has so our job as Physicians is to be
that sacred marketer
so cgms are one of my tools that I think
are so crucial so enchantment number two
yeah it's the real-time effect
so if you go get your glucose and
Insulin measured or maybe you do like a
two hour glucose challenge test where
you look at glucose and Insulin at the
fasting point one hour later two hours
later or more frequently
that does not have the same kind of
behavior effect as having continuous
data where you can say okay I drove to
see you Andrew from my place in Berkeley
and it was stressful it was torrentially
raining and I know my glucose was
elevated like I think really
understanding
what the
the mediators are of your glucose
control is essential now that said
it's also kind of a later effect I mean
I'd rather know your insulin and we know
from uh the white hat white Hall study
that insulin especially postprandial
insulin vascular insulin 2 can change
years and years before you get a change
in glucose
so um that's more for pre-diabetes and
diabetes so I think those are the main
reasons why I think it's such an
important tool
third thing is it democratizes data
which you do too I mean incredible how
you do that with your podcast but I
think one of the most hopeful and
exciting things that I'm seeing right
now
in the health space is that we're going
from
this patriarchal relationship where
doctors hold the power and are The
Gatekeepers of data to patients and
clients having much more access to that
enchantment about their own chemistry
and their own biology so to me that is
so exciting like for me to be able to
I've got you know probably 100 patients
that are in a data stream with me where
we're looking at their glucose and I can
I mean I'm on sabbatical so I'm not
doing this so much anymore but I can
call a patient be like why is your
glucose so high like what did you do oh
it was my birthday I had a piece of
birthday cake like that kind of
collaboration
that also is
teaching the patient to be their own
clinician to me that is a loop of
benevolence and integrity that I think
is essential to creating Health we've
got a disease care system we need the
democratization of data to become a
health-based system
Amen to that a million times over we
share that sentiment I can tell it at a
deep level I I think the pandemic
actually assisted in well harm to many
things but it assisted in people's
understanding that um no magic fairy nor
the government nor any anyone was going
to arrive at their door with a kit of
things to make them healthy right that
provide sunlight movement sleep and all
the various aspects of nutrition no
nothing nothing that everyone has to
have access to first and foremost and
then
Implement those things as best they can
speaking of which and kind of circling
back to this idea of people in their
late teens 20s 30s and onward
if you had a magic wand
and you could give like two or three
don'ts or to make it personal if you
could go back in time and
erase certain behaviors what would the
the don'ts category be
um you can tell us more than two or
three
um but if the goal is to maximize
vitality and Longevity and those are not
always uh parallel to one another right
they're certainly not the same thing
sometimes orthogonal but let's just say
fertility
being a proxy for vitality and Longevity
I think people will sometimes forget
this that fertility isn't just about
people who want to conceive children
it's also it's a it can serve as a proxy
for vitality and Longevity so what would
you like to see patients let's focus
first on female patients but
um if it extends to male patients as
well what would you like to see them not
do yeah or do far less of I really like
that
so I would say a few things I'll just
headline them and then we can go into
detail number one sleep
I do want to diverge from you a little
bit on some things but sleep is probably
not one of them oh well feel free I mean
you're the one that worked 100.
120 hours a week sleeping much then I
can't imagine unless unless you lived in
a different reality than I do
um uh you know and there are times in my
career where I was pulling all-nighters
and sleep deprived there's just it I
don't recommend it but I did it yeah I
hope you don't do that anymore no longer
if I can avoid it but there were years
many years where it was like all right
here we go and I'm quite
um
Adept at it for one cycle yeah but two
nights I kind of start to fall fall
apart totally yeah so I would say sleep
alcohol High perceived stress and I'd
love to talk about maybe
um the date on telomeres and what we
know so you'd like to see people get
enough sleep so don't don't just yeah
not all of these are concordant so um
not enough sleep too much alcohol too
much perceived stress
eating the wrong Foods
toxic relationships
and isolation and then number six
um
not moving enough or not moving and
exercising in a way that really fits
with your body so we start with that one
actually just because it's such a and
then work backwards um uh that's
interesting I I
think nowadays people appreciate the
need for quote unquote cardio I know
that the the exercise physiologists
cringe and and dissolve into a puddle of
Tears when I say that but getting the
heart rate up over some period of time
longer than 10 minutes
in order to generate cardiovascular
health circulation so and resistance
training of some kind maybe flexibility
what do you mean by Body phenotype or
and exercise I'll speak from personal
experience so what I did through I mean
I gave up my 20s to Medicine
and during that time I occasionally got
to the gym you know at UCSF on Parnassus
you could go to the gym and then as soon
as your beeper went off you're back into
the hospital
but I didn't exercise much I had um do
you remember Nordic tracks I had a
Nordic Track in my house and that was
that was like it what I believe because
for me the primary
outcome that I'm interested in is
cardiometabolic health
so when it comes to exercise what I
really feel
if we're going to be at a population
level
I feel that about a third cardio
two-thirds resistance training is based
on my synthesis of the literature the
best combination
and I think there's you know as you
described with your sign
um study I think there's a minimal
effective dose which for a population is
about 150 minutes I think most of us
need a lot more than that per week per
week but I think you know for me
because I have a phenotype that
produces a lot of insulin kind of
depending on
how I'm on my game I have a lot of
glucose so I have to exercise a lot more
to dispose that glucose so I think you
then have to move from medicine for the
population or prescriptions for the
population to what works for the
individual
I think that recommendation is fantastic
um I think resistance training well let
me put it this way I'm neither a trainer
nor a physician but I've seen in family
members that were doing
I wouldn't say a lot of cardio but just
cardio that when they add resistance
training everything in terms including
their biomarkers
um have improved dramatically yes in
particular for female members of my
family well one of the one of the
mediators that I think is important
especially for people who do what I call
chronic cardio which is what I did
is cortisol
so we know that
Runners especially marathon runners
people who do a lot of cardio and don't
do much resistance training they tend to
have much High cortisol levels and you
can buffer that with vitamin C vitamin C
can decrease the effect but
chronic cardio doesn't always serve
people so quick personal example when I
first started measuring hormone panels
in myself I went to my physician and I
said I'm 35. I've had one kid I want to
have another kid
I've never been so exhausted in my life
I just feel like I'm pushing a rock up
the hill
I've got this belly fat that I don't
like and
um
I don't want to have sex with my husband
so
what do you think what can we do about
this
and he offered
a birth control pill
and an antidepressant oh goodness so I
left him and I went to the lab and I ran
a hormone panel and my cortisol was
three times what it should have been my
insulin was in the 20s I was fasting my
glucose was 105.
my thyroid was mildly abnormal my
progesterone was low and that set me on
this course of realizing that
what I was doing as a physician taking
care especially of women was not getting
to some of these root causes that are so
essential and I would say I had to start
first with cortisol
at that time I was running four miles
three times a week four times a week
that was just racing my cortisol further
so that was not the right exercise for
me I needed more adaptive exercise I
started doing Pilates more yoga that
helped to lower my cortisol I mean it
started me on you know changing the way
I was managing perceived stress and it
also changed my supplement Richmond
can we talk about that and what the
moment you said lowering cortisol
thought of the two supplements that come
to mind are
um ashwagandha which I think can
potently reduce cortisol but I've heard
some recommendations about cycling it
and I've always wondered about time of
day for ashwagandha intake because sort
of quote unquote want cortisol elevated
in the early part of the day yes and we
know this
uh we know you do not want cortisol
peaking later in the day no you do not
interferes with sleep interferes with
sleep
um and then the other supplement is uh
rhodiola rosacea do I am I pronouncing
that correctly yeah so radiola is very
effective it's been shown in multiple
randomized trials to lower cortisol so
that could be very effective what sort
of doses I've started taking it recently
by the way and I made a huge mistake I
like to make the mistakes first so then
my audiences don't make them
um as I was taking it I heard it was an
adaptogen so I thought oh I'll take it
before resistance training but of course
you want the cortisol Peak during
resistance training because that's going
to set in motion the Adaptive response
so I start taking it later in the day
and it's really improved I would say my
late day second half of the day
cognition this is subjective to be fair
I just feel like I'm in a more even
plane of attention in the second half of
the day so you're describing an NF1
experiment right which is organic data
well it is not anecdotal so I was taught
at Harvard Medical School that the
hierarchy of evidence starts at the
lowest with expert opinion you know case
studies then you've got cohort studies
and you've got
observational data that's prospective
then you have randomized trial but the
highest quality evidence of all is the
end of one experiment where you serve as
your own control
so what you're describing with rhodiola
I would frame that as an end of one
experiment where you have a washout
period and you compare before and after
and I'd like to measure some other
metrics to see if there's an effect
including your cortisol so radial has
been shown in multiple randomized trials
to reduce cortisol
the other thing that I think is super
effective is phosphatidylserine PS for
short
fish oil also more modestly reduces
cortisol
ashwagandha is interesting so in my
first book the hormone cure
which I read by the way you did I did I
was hoping that was the one you read I
did I read it and it's spectacular and I
thought going into it I had this like
you know let's just call it what it was
it's called male bias like is there
going to be anything in here for me
because uh I'm I don't have ovaries and
you know it's gonna be and it was
immensely informative
um so thank you yeah I have very fun
Recollections of the the walks I took
listening to it and then I own the print
version too so I like to switch back and
forth so thank you for that it's a it's
a superb book for anyone to read yeah
yeah I so appreciate that
so
in chapter four you may or may not
remember that ashwagandha at least the
time that I wrote that book
ashwagandha's data is not great but lack
of proof is not proof against so with
ashwagandha most of the data comes from
thousands of years of using it in
ayurvedic medicine and it's considered
again not my science hat it's considered
a double adaptogen so that it's
potentially helpful when you are a high
cortisol phenotype like I was like I
sometimes still am
or low cortisol
I haven't found that in my patients
although I'll give you one exception
so ashwagandha is mostly based on animal
studies there's not as much human data
but it is used a ton in Integrative
Medicine
the
um there's one supplement that I found
to be incredibly helpful for people who
tend to have high cortisol at night
and that's called a cortisol manager
it's by integrative Therapeutics
I don't have a second
um supplement manufacturer that makes
something similar it's their number one
selling supplement because it's so
effective is it a cocktail of several
things it's a combination of
phosphatidylserine and ashwagandha so
tell me more about phosphatidylserine I
am familiar with it for it's been
mentioned by some guests that were on
the Tim Ferriss podcast long ago for
other reasons I think related to sleep
yes um and maybe that's another reason
why you like it um but before we move on
from rhodiola is there a dosage of
rhodiola rosacea that you um so I would
refer people to my book because the
randomized trials and the doses that
were used are in there so I can't
remember with rhodiola although I took
it this morning to prepare to be with
you yeah we can look it up and put a
show note caption so I can remember the
dose with phosphatidyl serum because I
take that regularly so 400 to 800
milligrams is the typical dose for PS
and what's interesting is that in the
randomized trials that were done
400 milligrams was more effective than
800 milligrams interesting I've found
that for several supplements that the
lower dose was more effective yes
um yeah I won't it doesn't matter what
those were and so when you say PS you
were referring to by the way folks not
PCOS just because
scientists and clinicians are familiar
with and Military very familiar with
acronyms uh phosphatidylserion PSO 400
to 800 milligrams 400 being more
effective taken later in the day or
early day does it matter it depends on
when your cortisol is high so for me I
tend to you know what's the pattern for
cortisol typically it rises to its peak
30 to 60 minutes after you get up then
it has this gradual kind of asymptotic
decline until you go to bed
so if you're someone like me who Peaks
like way crazy high I don't do that
anymore but that's what I used to do I
needed phosphatidylserine in the morning
for people who are high at night who
have what's known as a
a flat cortisol pattern or a inverted
pattern you want to take it at night
and the flat pattern just quick sidebar
is that that's associated with a number
of conditions that most mainstream
Physicians don't know about so a flat
pattern where it's low in the morning
and it's high at night is associated
with anxiety depression
uh decreased survival from breast cancer
that was studied at Stanford by David
Spiegel that's that he was my
um collab close even collaborator even
uh on the breath work study that we oh
interesting yeah he's our associate
chair of Psychiatry now so a wonderful
human being has amazed has been a guest
on this podcast and and I'm now
fantasizing about a conversation that
includes uh a panel of of uh Incredible
Minds like you and David from the
clinical side so in any case um yeah the
late shifted cortisol not good not good
and it seems to have the worst
immune Downstream
issues of any of the cortisol patterns
so that's really important to know about
because it then maps to things like
um
it's related to PTSD
so that's the pattern we see like in
vets who've got PTSD as well as others
it maps to autoimmunity it maps to
fibromyalgia
I was told that 1 in 12 people
um have are heterozygous so one mutant
copy or a hypomorphic for some some
mutation in adrenal related genes so
congenital adrenal hyperplasia is that
true and if so that means that 1 in 12
people walking around are cranking out
far too much cortisol or not enough
cortisol or the cortisol system is
already skewed in a direction that makes
life more challenging at the levels
we're talking about
um did I hear that correctly because
that 1 in 12 is not a small number it's
not a small number it fits with what I
see clinically
I mean I want to see that data just to
see
um what does that mean and could you
modulate it with environmental
influences but it certainly fits with
what I see you know I was taught once
again in mainstream medicine that in
terms of adrenal function
it's very binary how most clinicians
think about it you either have Addison's
disease and you don't make enough
cortisol or you've got cushions or
Cushing weed pattern and you make too
much cortisol and anything in the middle
is normal and my experience is that hell
no like there are those of us like me
who make a lot of cortisol I don't have
cushions maybe I've got one of these I
wouldn't call it a mutant Gene I would
call it more of a
vulnerable Gene so maybe I have one of
those maybe that's part of the reason
why I make you know two to three times
what I should be I'm aware of certain
groups of individuals from within the
military sector that
um have there's a more frequent
occurrence of
some mutation in CCH congenital adrenal
hyper prevention not necessarily two
copies which will if people look that up
they're going to go oh wow there's all
these phenotypes and
um but sort of hypomorphic type thing so
you know less than or too much cortisol
and they are very good at staying up
multiple days per night right multiple
nights in the series so they can pull
all-nighters very easily yeah they can
push harder when most people would quit
and everyone thinks well that's a great
phenotype to have but guess what it's
because they hyper produce cortisol yeah
and um so that's interesting and I think
if we were to panel medical students and
graduate students and you would look at
you know who's pulling excessively long
hours who's stressed out a lot even
outside of Academia and medicine and
pushing pushing pushing really hard I
think the ability to push and not crash
we think of it as adaptive but in some
sense it's maladaptive over a series of
years which is sort of what you
described earlier yeah it's such a good
point because
you know you in some ways you want to
select for that in certain professions
like in the military like in medicine
um
but I would wonder for those folks about
the downstream consequences of producing
so much cortisol oh it's got to be
detrimental for their health it's got to
be in the long run and and you see that
but even the data shows that if you're
someone like me who makes a lot of
cortisol
higher rates of depression like 50 of
people with major depression have high
cortisol levels higher rates of suicide
um much more metabolic dysfunction we
know that trauma as an example maps to
an increased risk of glucose metabolism
issues and certainly High cortisol does
that because it's one of the jobs of
cortisol is to manage a glucose
and it's
it kind of sets you up for
um this one
number five which is toxic relationships
you know someone who hyper produces
cortisol it's hard to live with someone
like that it's also I would say people
that have this
um let's just call it biological
resilience
it's not always adaptive because you can
stay in bad circumstances longer the
ability to to crash
provided it's not suicide or life life
destroying or you know long Arc of
of pause and the requirement to you know
take two years off from work or school
or something
um the ability to keep pressing on is a
double-edged sword let's put it that way
um I want to make sure in staying within
this conversation uh because you
mentioned Foster dial serine we talked
about rhodiola rosacea we talked a bit
about ashwagandha you've also talked
about Omega-3s and fish oil in
particular I'd love to know your
favorite sources of these I think
nowadays there's more General acceptance
that getting these essential fatty acids
is important do you have a threshold
level of sort of grams I I've encouraged
uh
um podcast listeners to consider
depending on what they're eating to try
and get a gram of EPA or more per day
does that seem excessive and what are
the real data on epa's because then the
cardiovascular experts always hit back
and say oh no you know it's not good for
cardiovascular health and then you go oh
it's better than antidepressants and
other studies and they go no so I feel
like if you really want to make your
life difficult if you want to raise your
cortisol you go on Twitter and you say
something positive about Omega-3s and
fish oil and
um and you learn a lot
um what are your thoughts on Omega-3s I
take a lot of them I've always been a
big fan yeah so this is where I
personalize I think some people need
more than others and what I do is I
measure your level so this gets back to
nutritional testing so for you I would
suggest an Omega Quant or one of my
favorite cardiometabolic panels is to do
a Cleveland heart lab so I think they
they give me the most reliable
information not just for lipids and
subclasses and you know NMR
fractionation but it also gives me an
insulin resistance score it gives me
um levels of Omega-3s great we'll
provide links to these different sites
so that people but one quick thing about
that the whole story is not Omega-3s and
taking fish oil so the work of Charlie
Sirhan at the Brigham is showing that
the way that we resolve inflammation
our understanding of it is really I
think in the learning to crawl stage and
so if you look at the omega-3 6 pathway
in the body
fish oils can help you know kind of push
the reactions in a particular direction
but typically they're not enough for the
resolution of inflammation now what most
people do including my MBA players is
they pop an ibuprofen or something like
that when they've got inflammation
that's got lots of other side effects
that are not so good for you and we know
in terms of the resolution of
inflammation that taking something like
ibuprofen reduces the amplitude of
inflammation by about 50 percent but
then it potentially blocks the complete
resolution of inflammation
so there's these new supplements that
you may have heard of called specialized
pro-resolving mediators there's a lot of
different supplement companies that make
them and that combined with fish oil
seems to be the best combination and
what I do for athletes who've got you
know kind of the normal aches and pains
of the training load they have is all
combine a little aspirin
small dose just like 81 milligrams or
two of those baby aspirin together with
fish oil plus specialized pro-resolving
mediators and there's some that are NSF
they're certified for sports but the
the dose I would say with my patients
some of them only need
a thousand milligrams your Gram that you
mentioned for the population some of
them need
six grams together with spms
so I think it has to be personalized
how young
um
is it okay for
people to start taking Omega-3s for
instance young women and their teens
people in their 20s and their 30s young
guys in their 20s and 30s should they
take fish oil if just as a assuming
they're not going to get anything tested
I'm thinking about the college student
who is really into biomarkers and that
sort of thing we'll go do some of this
um
but many people won't but they want to
do the right thing so they'll try and
drink a little less hopefully hopefully
they won't smoke or vape please don't
smoke or vape the idea that vaping is
okay it's like we had it was so bad so
bad for everything we're talking about
let's end that it's like exactly so just
you know avoid hopefully they'll try and
avoid those things hopefully they'll
avoid hard drugs
um hopefully they'll avoid getting any
STIs if they do they'll resolve them
quickly hopefully yes um so but they
might say oh well okay I'm willing to
you know take some magnesium or take
some phosphodel serine buffer my
cortisol eat some vegetables
um should they consider taking fish oil
as a kind of across-the-board
inoculatory thing so I put to rank order
these I would say fish oil yes
I think a thousand milligrams as a
general recommendation is good but I
also have a food first philosophy so my
preference would be that they're having
salmon or some kind of Smash fish and
they're getting that as the primary
source of their Omega-3s and then the
days that they don't have fish I
recommend it probably twice a week that
they take fish oil then I would put
magnesium next since so many people are
deficient then I'd probably put vitamin
D
what how many IU of vitamin D per day
well you keep asking me this like for
the the population yeah well for the let
me put it this way for the laze for the
lazy person
or and this is an or not an and or the
person who
um just doesn't have the finances to go
get measured yeah levels measured
because you know our audience is a huge
range we've got people who can have tons
of disposable income that list in the
spot we have people have no disposable
income so a thousand to two thousand
international units but my you know what
I do is I dose to a serum level that's
between about 50 and 90. great and so I
have a vitamin D receptor
uh snip and so I need to take about 5
000 a day to get to what I need a lot of
people don't need that
and you know there's some supplements
that
I don't know if they need so you
mentioned phosphatidylserine for someone
who's a college student and their
cortisol is completely normal they're
wasting their money on PS they don't
need it they might need it later but
they don't need it now I'd like to make
sure that we Circle back to birth
control in particular oral contraceptive
birth control
and we should touch on iuds perhaps
a little bit more but what are your
thoughts on sort of pure estrogen birth
control this is what I learned when I
was in college is that birth control is
basically tonic estrogen so constantly
taking estrogen estrogen women are
taking estrogen so that they don't get
the estrogen
priming of progesterone you're not
getting any ovulation and I've known
women that have been taking oral Contra
or that took oral contraception as like
estrogen
pills basically for 5 10 15 years are
there long-term consequences of this as
it relates to pregnancy PCOS
menopause what if so what are some of
those consequences
um
what are your concerns what do you like
about oral contraceptives what do you
dislike about them
I like how balanced you ask that
question so
women who take oral contraceptives as
long as you're describing like 10 years
or longer we call those Olympic oral
contraceptive users
in terms of benefit I think that
especially when they first came out and
even now it gives women reproductive
choice and That's essential
as you may know a reproductive Choice
has been declining recently so I'm a big
fan in that regard and we've got a lot
of data to show both the risks and also
the benefits of it
so I'll speak first into the benefits
because
uh I'm gonna get on a soapbox a little
bit about the risks so we know that it
reduces the risk of ovarian cancer so
there's something about this idea of
incessant ovulation that is not good for
the female body
so if you look at for instance women who
are nuns
who don't take oral contraceptives and
they have a period every single month of
their reproductive lives they have a
greater risk of a brain cancer
so if you look then at women who have uh
several babies and they've got a period
of time when they're pregnant that
they're not ovulating and then they
breastfeed for some period of time they
have a lower risk of ovarian cancer so
oral contraceptives help with reducing
ovulation and reducing risk we know that
if you take the oral contraceptive for
about five years it reduces your risk of
ovarian cancer by 50 and that's
significant because
were so poor at diagnosing ovarian
cancer early there's really no method
that's really effective we use ca125 and
ultrasound screen especially in women
who are at greater genetic risk but even
that often we diagnose it you know in a
later stage maybe just because that
statement is going to highlight for a
number of people the question of what
are some of the some earliest symptoms
that people can recognize without a
blood test so as ovarian cancer is it
going to be pain
so the problem is the symptoms are so
vague and they're so non-specific one of
the most common symptoms is bloating
and we've already talked about
constipation we've talked about how
women have this longer track GI tract
and so bloating is a really common
experience for most women
you can have bulk symptoms you know
feeling like your your lower belly is
kind of pressed out
so
the way that we
inform women in terms of watching for
this is to get regular gynecologic exams
for women who are at high risk where
they have for instance an ultrasound for
some reason it shows a mass that we're
concerned about there's a way to triage
that in terms of what kind of evaluation
that they need and that's the situation
where you might get a blood test called
the ca129
CA 125.
the um yeah the problem is the symptoms
are so vague it could be it depends on
how big the tumor is how much bulk you
have what it's pressing on
so if
um taking estrogen and thereby reducing
the frequency of ovulation
lowers the risk of ovarian cancer should
women that are even women who are not
sexually active so they're they're not
actively trying to get pregnant or avoid
getting pregnant but if they're not
sexually active then the probability of
conceiving unless they go through some
IUI or some other route is is very low
as far as I know
um so I was taught in high school anyway
um
would they be wise to suppress ovulation
for periodically using hormone-based
contraception just so that they can
offset the risk of ovarian cancer that's
a very rational question and I would say
that's what mainstream medicine has had
at its back to recommend oral
contraceptives not just for women who
are seeking contraception but
for acne for painful periods for really
kind of the drop of a hat they're
prescribing oral contraceptives that's
what I was taught to do
but there are so many consequences and I
think the issue here is more about
consent because
in OB GYN and I started out as a
board-certified ob gyn and I now mostly
see men but I was taught as an OB GYN to
convince women to go on the oral
contraceptive and I think a lot of that
is pharmaceutical influence
so maybe we could talk about the risks
and why the answer is no to your
question
um as we do that could I just ask is the
um the so-called ring the new it used to
be called The nuva Ring maybe that's a
brand name but when I was in college
there was all this discussion about the
ring all right by both men and women for
reasons that don't belong on the podcast
um use your imagination folks so
um is the the ring obviously it's not
oral it's not oral hormone contraception
but it's hormone based right the rate is
releasing estrogen locally as opposed to
taking it orally but would you would you
slot it under what you're about to tell
us in terms of the concerns
so we have less data about the ring
so the oral contraceptive is two
hormones it's ethanyl estradiol
and it's a progestin so it's not the
normal
uh progesterone that your body makes
such ovaries make and your adrenals make
it is a synthetic form of
progesterone
and it is the same
progestin similar same class that was
shown to be dangerous and provocative in
the women's health initiative so I'm not
a fan of progestins I do not recommend
them for any woman unless the
consequence of not taking them is
surgery or some other
um
you know unless it gives them some
freedom in some way so I don't like
Protestants the uh nuva ring is estrogen
plus progestin but it's released
transdermally through the vagina
so
given the the way that
um it's delivered to the vagina
the doses are lower than what's taken
orally
but in terms of some of the risks that
I'm about to talk about we don't know
about much of the data we think that
it's similar there's probably a spectrum
of risk and maneuvering is a little more
towards the middle than you know what
I'm talking about with oral
contraceptives
are you ready for that yeah I'm ready
for the risks okay
so like with almost any pharmaceutical
the oral contraceptive depletes certain
micronutrients
so magnesium there's certain vitamin B's
that are depleted
uh
it also affects the microbiome that data
is not as strong but there seems to be
some effect and there's also an
increased risk of inflammatory bowel
disease in autoimmune condition
it increases inflammatory tone
so the studies that I've seen increase
one of the markers of inflammatory tone
High sensitivity CRP by about two to
three x
it seems to make the hypothalamic
pituitary adrenal axis more rigid
so that you can't kind of roll with the
punches and Wax and Wane in terms of
cortisol production the way that you can
off the birth control pill
it can affect thyroid function
I'm thinking of the slide that I have
that has like 10 problems associated
with oral contraceptive but that's what
I can remember right now that's very
helpful and it makes me wonder whether
or not if on the one hand oral
contraceptives are protective in women
it's ovarian cancer but then they have
these other issues yeah there's one
other I want to mention please
anytime you take oral estrogen it raises
sex hormone by Nick globulin and you've
talked to other podcast guests about
this Kyle I think sex hormone binding
globulin I think of as a sponge that
soaks up free estrogen and free
testosterone so when you go on the birth
control bill you raise your sex hormone
binding globulin it soaks up especially
free testosterone
and for some women it's not a big deal
they don't notice much of a difference
but then there's a phenotype maybe
related to CAG repeats on the Androgen
receptor
who are exquisitely sensitive to that
decline in free testosterone so this
then opens the portal of talking a
little bit about testosterone in women
so we've mentioned already that it's the
most abundant biologically the most
abundant hormone in the female system
even though men make almost 10 times as
much or even more than 10 times it is so
important for women it is essential to
so many things not just sex drive and
muscle mass and seeing a response to
resistance training but also confidence
in agency
and so those women who are so sensitive
to their testosterone level they've got
this high sex hormone binding globulin
their testosterone declines
what they describe is vaginal dryness
maybe a decline in sex drive but there's
also this bigger issue related to
confidence in agency even risk-taking
from studies that we've done with MBA
students that I think is a serious
problem
maybe the most important out of all of
these things is that it can shrink the
clitoris by up to 20 percent
twenty percent and that includes the
regression of the of the nerves that
innervate the the clitoris is that I
mean that's a very good question as a
neuroscientist yeah I would think uh I
used to teach uh the neural side of of
reproductive Health we need to do a
series on Sexual Health maybe you would
co-host that with me
we could certainly use your expertise I
think um yeah that's a dramatic that's
interesting number yeah but then let's
go back to the sacred marketing if I've
got a woman that I think should not be
on the birth control pill maybe she's
taking it for acne or she's taking it
because her periods were a little
painful what I'm going to do is say
let's leverage these other ways of
making your period less painful let's
take the message of your painful periods
and figure out okay it's your
inflammatory tone and we give you some
fish oil and spms maybe a little aspirin
when you've got your period like let's
find some other ways to deal with it
then to take the oral contraceptive
which you have not received informed
consent about because it can trick your
by up to 20 now that usually
convinces most people to come reversible
the elevation in sex hormone binding
globulin does not seem to go away when
you come off the birth control pill
to me that is the biggest problem with
prescribing oral contraceptives now the
data that we have is limited there's one
woman who uh Claudia has something
something who looked at sex hormone
binding globulin a year out from
stopping the birth control pill and it
was still elevated it wasn't as high as
it was when they were on the pill but it
was still elevated so your question
about reversibility
I don't know if we know the answer to
that
wow okay
um
that's yeah that's a significant
statement
and something that for consideration
related to this although this might seem
not related it is
how early do you recommend that women go
get their
follicle number assessed in other words
to get a size a sense of the size of the
ovarian reserve and their amh levels
measured um
I'm gonna I'm an amateur Outsider as I
say this but we have an episode on a
fertility where I just described the
ovulatory menstrual cycle yeah
um and I'm not the best person to answer
that yeah well I'm too far out from it
okay well um I suppose then from taking
the perspective of somebody who thinks
about fertility it in terms of at least
congruent with vitality and Longevity
given that it's fairly non-invasive it's
an ultrasound or a blood draw for amh or
both
is there any reason why a woman would
not want to get her follicle number
assessed or her amh levels assessed is
there any reason
why because I was shocked to learn that
most women don't do this until they're
hitting their late 30s or early 40s and
yeah they're having conceived or they
suddenly decide that they want to
conceive and I thought why doesn't every
doctor insist that their female patients
get have their amh level
addressed so that if they need to freeze
eggs cost it's cost yeah so I think if
you've got the disposable income to do
it go for it it's not included in a
standard blood panel no wow the only
women in my practice who've had amhs
done and have looked at their follicle
count are women who
want to freeze their eggs or and that
requires disposable income or they
um are having trouble getting pregnant
so they are in the reproductive
Endocrinology system and they're getting
an evaluation and then they're also
um the women who have symptoms of early
menopause so premature ovarian
insufficiency which is before age 40.
uh those are the women that I see
getting attested and I think you're
right that it should be offered more
broadly it speaks to the democratization
of data again
and I think most women don't know that
so you're doing a huge service I think
to be speaking into this
one other point related to that is that
what I see in conventional medicine
is that when a woman asks for a hormone
panel
and she's not trying to get pregnant she
usually gets told
that hormones vary too much
it's a waste of money you don't need it
or if you're feeling hormonal why don't
you go on a birth control pill
unless she's trying to get pregnant
if she's trying to get pregnant suddenly
those same tests are very reliable and
they get you know their their
testosterone their free testosterone
their thyroid panel they get their
estrogen and progesterone maybe they get
their cortisol they get their amh so
there's a double standard
between those who want to get pregnant
and those who don't and that needs to
end
I totally agree as I've learned more
about
um ovulatory cycle and amh and and the
antral population of follicles on it
it's fascinating it just seems to me wow
a relatively straightforward test one
definitely invasive ultrasound but I
don't consider that yeah that's not I'm
not terribly invasive but invasive uh at
least but the other one just pure blood
test just seems like why wouldn't I
wouldn't this be offered or covered by
insurance or or you know that anyone
that wanted but now now I understand why
you mentioned menopause
huge topic enormous topic we had a guest
on the podcast who's not a clinician who
said something in passing so I wanna I'm
likely to get this wrong
um but what they said was that the
results of the large-scale trials on
hormone replacement therapy for women
for menopause said something to the
effect of if the hormone therapy was
started early enough it was very
beneficial for yes vitality and health
outcomes whereas if women
went through menopause and then
initiated the hormone therapy
hormone replacement therapy that it
could be detrimental to their health
so first of all do I recall that
statement correctly and then second of
all what sorts of hormones are being
replaced is it just estrogen and how is
that done is it done through birth
control so oral contraceptives nuvarings
what are your thoughts on menopause when
should people start thinking about it
and what is the
palette of things available so that we
can do an entire episode with you on on
this topic in the future but just to I
you know I get a lot of questions about
this and and I'm guessing based on
everything you've told me today that
there are women in their 30s that while
they may be 20 years out from menopause
probably should be doing things now in
anticipation of that yes so we haven't
talked about the 30 something but I
totally agree with you the more you know
about your phenotype your hormonal
phenotype when you're in your 30s you're
set up in terms of what to do in the
future especially things like your
thyroid your estrogen and progesterone
levels because you can replace
to a state of Youth thyroid
whatever that is for you
you can replace I don't usually go
exactly back to where the estrogen and
progesterone levels were but we can get
pretty close so in your 30s having a
base case I think is really essential
so you spoke to the Women's Health
Initiative which was published in 2002
and we went from a huge number of women
taking hormone therapy to a very small
percentage like in the range of five
percent
and that means we've got millions
millions of women who are suffering
needlessly with things like insomnia
difficulty with their mood difficulty
with sex drive feeling like they are
closing the store in terms of sex
because they're not on hormone therapy
I would agree with the statement that
you made that hormone therapy particular
forms that are similar to what your body
always made when it's given judiciously
at the right time
typically within five to ten years of
menopause which is 51 to 52 that it is
incredibly safe so
it's a complicated study the women's
health initiative but it was the the
wrong study in the wrong patients
with the wrong medications
and
um with some of the wrong outcomes so it
was powered to look at cardiovascular
outcomes it was not powered to look at
breast cancer it was stopped because of
breast cancer risk but what happened in
the control arm of the study was that
they had an incredibly low rate of
breast cancer
and so as a result they ended up having
this increased risk of breast cancer at
five years and they stopped the study
now the study was done with synthetics
it was done with conjugated equine
estrogen known as Premarin and medroxy
progesterone acetate those were the
so-called estrogen and progesterone
those are synthetic hormones we think
especially the progestin is associated
with the greater risk of breast cancer
although the the subsequent
re-evaluations of the data now 18 years
out have shown that
um
this problem with the control group and
no increased risk of breast cancer
um
and for the women who got estrogen only
those who had a hysterectomy the
Premarin they actually had a decreased
breast cancer risk and decreased breast
cancer mortality
so there's a lot to be said about this
I'm trying to keep it really brief
but if you look at the women 50 to 60 So
within 10 years of menopause they're the
ones who seem to have the greatest
benefit
so they had a decreased subclinical
atherosclerosis so less cardiovascular
disease they had an improvement in terms
of bone health
um less progression to diabetes and then
over the age of 60 they started to have
greater risk of certain outcomes such as
cardiovascular disease myocardial
infarction and so on
you asked about
um
what do I do
and
to me this problem is not just menopause
what's more interesting is to talk about
perimenopause
so perimenopause is the the period of
time before your final menstrual cycle
and for most women depending on how it's
tuned you are to the symptoms it can
last for 10 years so I'm still in Period
menopause it's been like 20 years
because I've been tracking it so
carefully
it usually gets kicked off by having
your cycle get closer together so that
could happen in your 30s or your 40s you
go from 28 days to 25 days that sort of
thing you may notice that you start
sleeping more poorly because
progesterone is so important you talked
about that with Kyle
you may notice it as more anxiety
difficulty is sleeping and that probably
is related to the estrogen receptor so
your Alpha is estrogen receptor Alpha is
anxio
it increases anxiety
ER beta is associated with an anxiolytic
activity and then there's a total of
about six estrogen receptors now there's
the the g-protein-coupled estrogen
receptors and those are mixed anxiolytic
anxiogenic
so um there's this whole period of
perimenopause and what's Most
Fascinating to me and we've got to talk
about this either today or another time
is that there is this massive massive
change that happens in the female brain
that people are not talking about enough
and so looking at the work of Lisa
Moscone at Cornell
from uh starting around age 40. there is
this massive change in cerebral
metabolism so you can do fdg pet scans
you can look at glucose uptake and
there's about
on average a 20 decline from
pre-menopause
you know up to like age 35
to perimenopause to post menopause
the women who are having the most
symptoms in perimenopause menopause The
Hot Flashes the night sweats the
difficulty of sleeping those are the
ones who have the most significant
cerebral hypomatabolism
so it's almost like a
um I don't I don't want to scare people
with this language but it's a
low level or let's call it pseudo
dementia of sorts yes it it seems to be
a phenotype that you can then map
to Alzheimer's disease because that's
Lisa moscone's work she's looking at
okay
Alzheimer's disease is not a disease of
old age it is disease of middle age what
are some of the biomarkers that we can
Define that can tell you what your risk
is I've got a mother and a grandmother
with Alzheimer's disease you can believe
I am all over this data and insulin
resistance it's a huge part of
sensitivity as we talked about before
um seems to be somewhere in there which
I think when that first when that idea
first surfaced a few people like really
but then of course right I mean the
brain is just incredibly metabolically
demanding organ
you deprive neurons of
fuel sources they or you make them less
sensitive to fuel sources they start
dying they certainly start firing less
it makes perfect sense and I think now
it's thanks to Lisa's work work that
you've you've done and talked about
quite a lot is um in your books and
elsewhere I think has really you know
highlighted for people that
metabolism and metabolomics is going to
be as important as genes and genomics
when it comes that's right dementia
perhaps especially in women is it safe
to say that I think I think so because
we believe that this system is regulated
by estrogen
so the decline in estrogen starting
around age 40 43 is kind of the average
seems to be the driver behind cerebral
hypomatabolism the way I describe it to
my patients is
it's like slow brain energy
so you walk into a room you can't
remember why like you just notice that
you can't manage all the tasks the way
that you once could like things are just
a little slower
and I say that to women and they're like
I have that like help me
so this is then circling back to Whi
where women are scared to death of
taking hormone therapy and we've got all
of these women that are Marching toward
potentially a greater risk of
Alzheimer's disease and they have this
opportunity in their 40s and their 50s
to take hormone therapy and they may not
be offered it
because the typical conventional
approach based on Whi is to say
unless you're having hot flashes and
night sweats that are severe I'm not
going to give you hormone therapy and I
I just want to call that out I would say
no that is not the way to approach it
further
the concept right now in conventional
medicine is that hot flashes and night
sweats are these nuisance symptoms that
we will take care of temporarily maybe
with a little bit of estrogen
progesterone or birth control pill
because it's given a lot or that they
pass or is that this idea you know suck
it up suck it up
doesn't matter that you're not sleeping
anymore you know turn down the
temperature in your room
and that's not right because
hot flashes and night sweats are a
biomarker
of cardiometabolic disease they are a
biomarker of increased bone loss
they are a biomarker of changes in the
brain
so many of these symptoms that occur in
perimenopause are not driven by the
ovaries they are driven by the brain
yeah it's the the bi-directional
crosstalk between the body and the brain
keeps you know I think is this
resounding theme uh we had Chris Palmer
on here a psychiatrist who's talking
about ketogenic diet mental health I
know uh you we could have a whole other
discussion and we will I hope if you'll
agree to it about nutrition and as it
relates to hormones uh specific diets
and and so forth but the and that's a
question too whether this problem of
cerebral hyper metabolism
could we solve it with estrogen
and or increased metabolic flexibility
so I just wanted to footnote that sorry
to interrupt you no please uh please
interrupt um uh I know Europe as long as
we're there I know you are a fan in some
instances of intermittent fasting time
restricted feeding and or ketogenic diet
yes
um to get cells sensitive to insulin
which is not to say if I understand
correctly which is not to say that women
need to stay on the ketogenic diet for
long periods of time
or intermittent fast for my only time
restricted feeding for eight hours or
six hours a day but that by increasing
you said metabolic flexibility
excuse me but by increasing cells
sensitivity to insulin and then maybe
returning to a more typical eating
pattern and periodically switching back
and forth that might actually benefit be
beneficial do I have that right yeah I
love the pulse so I feel like it's much
more physiologic than say going on a
ketogenic diet and staying there for
years all of the data that we have on
the ketogenic diet
it's pretty Limited in terms of duration
you know the the longest players that we
have in terms of the data are the focus
with epilepsy and that's just a
different phenotype so I think in terms
of microbiome effects diversity
dysbiosis some of those issues we really
don't know in terms of long-term effects
so I prefer with a ketogenic diet that
it's used as an NF1 experiment and that
to do it for four weeks maybe you
measure biomarkers before and afterwards
maybe look at your stool before and
afterwards we still haven't talked about
stool tests yet but you could measure
your fasting insulin and your glucose
you could just start there do four weeks
of Keto clean keto including vegetables
it doesn't have to be 57 a day and then
measure it again afterwards
since you mentioned a mentioned stool
testing yes
what what is your recommendation about
stool testing
so my recommendation this is again in
the the field of if you have the
disposable income so I usually start
with Genova because they've got a good
copay system with insurance that's what
I typically use so I usually do their
one day stool test where you have to go
digging through your stool and send it
off to the slab that's in North Carolina
I usually do the one day unless I'm
concerned about parasites in that case I
tend to do three days I do that for
people who travel a fair amount and go
to places where there's greater risk or
they just have gut symptoms
another test that I do a lot is
um because I always like to mention two
Labs is a test by longevity
and this is much more of a data wonk
uh type of test because it's powered by
AI it was designed by
um
a guy who's got inflammatory bowel
disease and he is a
um he's a PhD
deep phenotyping bioinformatics guy who
wanted to make this really easy
so the test is is Under the Umbrella of
thorn
and
um they just call it got bio they might
have another name for it and they just
improved it so that it's just a wipe
instead of digging through her stool and
so my athletes will do it now they were
not so into digging through their stool
before is anybody really no one is I
don't want the answer
I know the answer I prefer to that but
that's a super interesting test because
it's
you get much more dense data the issue
is
um with apologies to my friends at
Thorne the issue is that there are
recommendations end up being sworn
supplements so that can be very easy for
people who want to you know connect the
dots
that's not always the way that I like to
do it uh first of all
three things
um
you've shared with us an immense amount
of knowledge and
in that first statement I also want to
apologize because I threw at you the
entire life span of uh female lifespan
reproductive Health contraception diet
uh microbiome so many things but
um I first I just want to say
you've taught me a tremendous amount
um
including I think something that most
people including myself have not thought
about enough which is the psychosocial
impact on things that we're all familiar
with
constipation bowel movements what we eat
what we avoid I have to say really a
huge thank you for that because
it's not something that's been discussed
on this podcast before sort of know that
brain communicates with body psychology
and biology are linked but I think this
is the first time that anyone's ever
directly linked
circumstances and biology and psychology
in such a concrete way so that's that's
the first thing and I speak for many
people in that second of all
we barely scratched the surface of your
knowledge and um which is both uh
frustrating for me because uh it I
always want to learn more and I know
many other people do as well but also
very very exciting because uh with uh
hopefully without much persuasion we can
have you back on to talk about something
at all like meant uh I know you're
working with men now Men's Health
um some particulars around I think
there's more for us to explore in terms
of PCOS menopause contraception and all
of the above but then something that you
and I were talking about off camera
um before we started which I think is a
really important factor that ties back
to this issue of of
trauma and stress and the bi-directional
relationship between biology and
psychology hopefully someday we won't
even separate those two
which is the use of specific medicines
including plant medicines yes and how
that can influence overall health which
no doubt will include Hormone Health
so I say all of that for two reasons
first of all to queue up the
we won't even call it a part two but a
sequel to the to this with
um I'm gratified to hear that you you'll
join us for that and then also to just
really extend a huge thank you the
amount of knowledge that you shared is
is immense and uh is going to be very
very useful and actionable for for men
in terms of their thinking and their
actions and
for women in particular today's
discussion in particular for women in
terms of how to think about their health
and biology how to think about their
psychology and the environment that all
of that's embedded in so I just want to
say an enormous thank
you thank you Andrew I so appreciate
that and I so appreciate
what you offer to the world in terms of
a weigh-in a way to understand
physiology and how to craft a architect
a better life
um can I just add one last thing because
I didn't talk about it since we didn't
get to the 40s and the 50s and those
listed biomarkers so I feel like if
people if women went away with one thing
today it would be to do a coronary
artery calcium score
by age 45 and sooner if you've got
premature heart disease how is that
taken so it's a CT scan of the chest
you can self-order it like I think at
Stanford Hospital you can self-order it
last time a patient checked it was 250
so again disposable income but it it
tells you it it almost gives you this
fork in the road in terms of how much
you need to pay attention to
cardiometabolic health as a woman and
it's uh 45 for men too so if you haven't
had one if you had one no you need one
insulin cortisol CAC great so I'll run
all that by you it's really essential
and it's um
yeah it's it's so fascinating because
you know there's some women who have a
zero so my score is zero and that's
great so often you can just keep doing
what you're doing but if you're 45 and
you're starting to be elevated or you've
got you know maybe you've got PCOS or
you've got some other biomarkers tending
you in this direction toward the number
one killer really
it's nine out of the top 10 killers in
the US
that allows you to really start to make
changes and I I think it's essential to
know that data it's not it's probably
not going to be offered by your doctor
certainly Peter attia is going to offer
it but most conventional doctors are not
going to do it and then the last thing I
want to say before you mention so if I
were to go to my doctor and I just say I
want a cardiac calcium score that's what
people coronary artery calcium scores
CAC okay so everyone hear that and know
that if you're 40 or older and maybe if
you're 45 45 or older get get it
so the last thing is and this is for men
and women is there a score
so adverse childhood experiences knowing
your a score is so essential in terms of
a baseline for how much trauma your
system your Pine system endured when you
were a kid and we know that childhood
trauma whether it's abuse or neglect or
you know having an alcoholic parent that
maps to disease in middle age and it can
give you so much Insight I'll give you
an example I've got a patient who had an
elevated coronary artery calcium score
who does everything right with her food
I think it was her trauma that elevated
her CAC when she was 45. so I think an a
score knowing your a score
starting as a teenager like knowing it
and knowing how to work with that is
really essential there are certain
people they are exceedingly rare but you
are one such person that when they speak
knowledge just comes from comes out of
them and it's incredibly useful and
helpful knowledge so thank you I'm gonna
get both of those things good
um and I highly recommend everyone else
pursue ways that they can get those or
if they can't get them that they you
know
Your Mark those as things to get at the
point where they they can obtain
sufficient uh disposable income sounds
like that the health uh the detriments
to health that those can offset would be
well worth the cost totally
thank you thank you for joining me for
today's discussion all about female
hormone Health vitality and Longevity
with Dr Sarah Gottfried if you'd like to
learn more about Dr Gottfried's work
please check out her social media
channels we've provided links to those
in the show note captions in addition
please check out one or all of Dr
Gottfried's excellent books that she's
written about nutrition supplementation
and various treatments for Hormone
Health longevity and vitality we've
linked to two of those notably women
food and hormones and her book the
hormone cure in our show note captions
if you're learning from and or enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on
Spotify and apple and in addition on
both Spotify and apple you can give us
up to a five star review if you have
questions or comments or topics or
guests that you'd like me to cover on
the huberman Lab podcast please put
those in the comments section on YouTube
I do read all the comments in addition
please check out the sponsors mentioned
at the beginning of and throughout
today's episode that's the best way to
support this podcast if you're not
already following us on social media we
are huberman lab on Instagram Twitter
Facebook and Linkedin and I should
mention that on both Instagram and
Twitter I cover science and science
related tools for mental health physical
health and performance some of which
overlap with the contents of the uberman
Lab podcast but much of which is
distinct from the contents of the
huberman Lab podcast again it's huberman
lab on all social media channels and if
you haven't already subscribed to the
human Lab podcast so-called neural
network newsletter that's a monthly
newsletter it's completely zero cost and
we provide summaries of podcast episodes
as well as summaries of tools for
everything from optimizing sleep to
Hormone Health deliberate cold exposure
deliberate heat exposure Fitness and so
on it's very easy to sign up for you go
to hubermanlab.com go to the menu and
scroll to newsletter you simply provide
your email we do not share your email
with anybody as I mentioned before it is
completely zero cost again that's the
neural network newsletter and you can
find it at hubermanlab.com during
today's episode and on many previous
episodes of the huberman lab podcast we
discuss supplements while supplements
aren't necessary for everybody many
people derive tremendous benefit from
them for everything from sleep to focus
to hormone regulation the huberman Lab
podcast is happy to announce that we
partnered with momentous supplements
because momentous supplements are the
absolute highest quality also they
include many single ingredient
formulations which is essential if you
wanted to design a supplement regimen
that is both cost effective and the most
biologically effective supplement
regimen that's very hard to do with
blends of supplements it's very
straightforward to do with single
ingredient formulations also momentous
supplements ship internationally which
is important because we realize that
many of you reside outside of the United
States if you'd like to see the
supplements discussed on the huberman
Lab podcast you can go to live momentous
spelled ous so that's livemomentis.com
huberman thank you once again for
joining me for today's discussion all
about female hormone Health vitality and
Longevity with Dr Sarah Gottfried and
last but certainly not least thank you
for your interest in science
[Music]